I'll tell you right now, if I was Tom, I
would be clapping. I'd be like, "Yes,
yeah, let's go." Like, how could you not
if you're in that situation, right? So,
I'm just trying to ruin your career with
like heinous lies and like that, right?
I get it sounds like Destiny, but
Destiny's a loser.
>> Thank you for the following.
>> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I
don't feel bad for Chud. Chud went live.
This thing came out at like what was
like between 6:00 and 10:00 the night
before and he was up by 8:00 a.m. saying
the great sweep is on and sicked his
entire [__] audience on me. I don't
feel bad for Chud, not one bit.
>> The whole conversation we we were at
initially, you said, "Why can't we all
get along and make content? We can't." I
said, "We can't make content cuz Nick's
a [__] problem." And now you're just
It's like you're just saying, "Yeah,
Nick's [__] problem. He doesn't want
content with anyone." [music]
This is leading into the next story we
got here. Give me a second. [music] So,
Nicholas
on Twitter is basically saying that, you
know, Sacramento posts this text. All
right.
And this text says, "I forgot to mention
Turkey Tom's ex attempted to dox an
offline person I attended VidCon with in
2025. This was done because she must
have known something and she wanted us
to suffer for simply knowing Tom. This
worthless gets no sympathy from me."
Where where's the doxing? What is the
doxing element here? Can anybody tell me
where the doxing element is? Cuz I I
don't see it. Not to sweep. Oh, don't
worry about it, Auggie. Actually,
Auggie, if you want to talk about any of
this, we we could totally talk about it.
No, by all means, give me the other side
of the story because right now this
looks very goofy to me, right? And I
would say possibly fishing is bad. Yeah.
Or requesting docs is very bad, right? I
don't like this. I don't like this,
Auggie. I'll be real with you. I'm not a
fan. I'm not a fan. I don't I don't
think you dox people even in this case.
You know what I'm saying? Not a fan. I
The Brandon Buckingham doxing thing is
pretty bad. Okay. This this dying is he
really is he really dying and he's like
just throwing out a last minute dox.
That's up. He's got nothing left. Dude,
it's it's crazy. Hold on. According to
her, we all deserve to get nuked and she
was actively looking for information on
her. I assume Nicholas's girlfriend. I
find it absolutely hilarious that she
was the only one to end up getting
blasted. And nobody can convince me why
that isn't funny. As a Kiwi farmer, you
cannot cry about doxing. It's
impossible. Or are you saying she can't
cry about it? Yeah, but that's different
from what I expect of other people,
right? Yeah, that's different from what
I expect of other people.
I don't think you could just say, "Well,
it's fair game to go on Kiwi Farms and
Dox people." I think this also got some
sinister implications as well for
anybody who might have another
allegation against Dom that you I you
got to admit the optics are not good.
Okay, the optics are not good of, "Yeah,
this person said this, they came out
with an allegation." And while I think
she's been categorically disproven to
just like instantly the day Tom drops
his response, post her essentially her
full docks. That's wild, dude. That's
wild.
I'm not I'm not saying she didn't
deserve to be like mocked out of the
room for everything she's posted.
I just don't know. I don't know if I'm
at doxing yet, that's all. Uh she's been
trying to ruin his life. I don't know if
it's justified, but I just don't care.
Yeah. Well, unfortunately for us, we had
to deal with, you know, certain person
using that exact logic to justify
doxing, you know, people I know, people
I'm friends with, right? Oh, well,
they're trying to ruin my life, so I
don't care if they're I I don't care.
I'm just doxing them now. It's like
trying to figure that out, right? Um,
she was definitely going to Well, hold
on. If she was definitely going to Why
doesn't she just dox the anonymous
VidCon girl?
If she was just going to That That's my
question, right? If you were just going
to dox the anonymous VidCon girl, in my
opinion, why would you Sorry. If you
were trying to dox the the Doryo
girlfriend cuz she was allies with that
girl. Okay. Wait, do you want to call
in, Auggie? Would it be easier to do
this call over voice? I don't think I'm
in my channel. Would you want to call
in? We don't have to do this through
chat.
>> Yo yo, what's going on, man? Um, it just
seems like she obviously wanted to post
that information because she was mad
because she was claiming that, and this
could be true, by the way. I don't know
if it's true or not, but she was
claiming that Turkey Tom cheated on her
at VidCon, right? And this VidCon girl
knew about the whole situation and she
was in communication with the VidCon
girl uh because Dioro's girlfriend had
told her about all this type of stuff,
right? Like Tom had a girl back home or
something like that, right? And so she
was mad and she wanted to get that
information. Everybody in the Kiwi Farms
thread was obviously and I'm sure you
know how Kiwi Farms works, right?
Obviously, they were going for
>> release anything. Yes. Yes. Of course.
And so she was going to completely with
that
>> dude. It's like null, you know, asking
both of the girls when he has them on a
call. He's not asking for like
contemporaneous texts that prove
anything. He's like, "How big is Tom?"
>> He wants dirt. He want Everyone on that
side wants dirt. They don't actually
give a about like for like the
allegation or anything like that. They
just want funny material to make memes
of basically, right?
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> Yeah. Sure.
>> Yeah.
>> I just I I So I agree with you that
that's what they want. And I agree with
you. She's definitely gotten into a
pattern or both of these girls have, I
think, of trying to get the approval of
the thread, which is never going to go
well for anybody. Gay. Don't try to get
their approval. They don't like you. The
second [laughter] you stop being useful,
they will totally turn on you.
>> Yes. They're animals.
I mean,
sure, there are anonymous people on the
internet. They're right there some
accountants on here, right?
>> I don't blame them. If I was like
anonymous on the internet, I would be an
animal, too, cuz I wouldn't give a,
right? But I'm just saying like that's
how they are.
>> Like I'm guessing some of them are like
totally normal people outside of this.
This is like their little, you know,
their catharsis.
>> It's just fun. It's sport.
>> Yeah. But I again I haven't seen an
indication that at least yet
>> that she would post this.
>> Why would anything and everything else?
Like what do you mean?
>> Humiliating Tom.
>> Did she post, you know, location
information on somebody else? I think
>> she was understand the difference,
right?
>> Well, she was obviously going after me
and Nick, too. I mean, she for one
thing, I'll tell you this, right? She
lied and said that I lied because on my
stream when I covered the Tom
allegations, she said that I lied by
saying I didn't know her even though Tom
told me that he was dating her. Okay,
Tom told me he was dating some girl from
Tinder. I didn't know who she was. I
didn't know what her name was. I didn't
know her face, what she looked like,
literally anything about her. All I knew
was at some point Tama told me, "Oh, by
the way, I'm dating some girl that I met
from Tinder." Right? So on my stream
when I said I didn't know her, she tried
to say that I was lying and saying that
oh Aie knew who I was because Tom uh
told me about her or Tom Tom told him
about me or whatever, right? It's like
that's not true at all. You know what I
mean by that, right? So she was gunning
for Nick. She was gunning for me and she
was looking for anything she could post
about us later on after she had run out
of funny juicy things to say about Tom.
The idea that she would not have posted
Dioro's girlfriend's information when
obviously she's fine posting everything
else about Tom and everything else about
his friends and everything else about,
you know, literally anything she can
just to make his life miserable. I just
find that hard to believe.
>> Hold on. Why are we totally fine with,
you know, Tom? I I'll just say Tom
making videos on the embarrassing
personal details of all these people who
get it gets leaked on Kiwi Farms, but
not fine with him like doxing people.
It's because doxing is like a totally
different thing and most people
understand that, right? So I while I
understand that she is posting stuff to
get back at people and she's really mad
at Tom, I think I've not seen anything
to me that shows that she would go and
just dock someone yet. I mean, she's
posting on a forum that's literally his
docs. Like what do you mean?
>> Like that's literally what the whole
forum is about, right? like the the
front page, you can't even show the
forum the front page of the forum
because it's his full legal name and if
you go to the first post or whatever,
right? I'm sure it has his address and
everything about it on there, right? How
could you moralize about that?
>> Could be. How could I moralize if she's
posting on QB Farms about her? I don't
think so. I think she's going after Tom.
I just I'm saying she hasn't doed when
you post on indication she's going to
dox somebody.
>> I feel like when you post on QB Farms,
you just forfeit the right to even
complain about doxing at all because
it's like that is the website where But
they don't even see that as like an act
of aggression.
>> Just to be clear, I'm not arguing that
you, you know, if she complained about
this when she's participating in a forum
that is doxing Tom and probably doxing
some of his friends, I would guess. I'm
not saying she could complain about it.
I'm saying I don't like I don't want
people around me to join this culture
because I want the ability to say I
don't hang out with people who are just
going to dox random dudes. Like I don't
want that because I don't want that to
happen to me, right? I think it's bad.
>> That's fair. That's fair. I'm saying
it's bad.
>> I'm right.
>> That's completely fair. That's
completely fair. Um
I think there is some amount of context
as to like certain things like when
people are doxed or whatever, right?
Like Brandon doing doxing her is not
just some random attack or whatever,
right? Obviously, there's a reason why
he's motivated to do that. And you can
say whether it's right or it's wrong or
something like that, right? But I think
we can look at that situation and just
see it as like different than just like
a random attack happening or something
like that, right?
>> Absolutely. But like you understand
that's just the exact logic Destiny used
to dox people, right?
>> Uh do doxing who?
>> Like it's not it's like not uh trying to
dox me, trying to dox a bunch of other
people. I don't even want to say other
names, but like he's basically like
these people tried to talk about my
[__] They tried to like go after me for
this and they should have their
identities exposed on the internet.
Right. So, it's not like a random docs.
He like feels like he's justified in
doing it. Right.
>> Right.
>> Obviously, if you're wrong by somebody,
you might feel like you're justified to
do it. Doesn't make it okay to do
>> in my opinion.
>> Yeah.
Um,
>> I understand that you guys are like you
guys are like friends and I do
understand the idea that this person did
try to ruin Tom's reputation, did try to
ruin his career, and you feel like
something should be done about it. I
just would hesitate to say that the
appropriate response is doxing
immediately because of it basically is
like you opening up a can of worms once
you support this sort of like
>> Yeah. I mean, I get the I get the
hesitation as an outsider looking in on
it or whatever, right? I don't know. For
me, like looking at it from my
perspective, when I saw Brandon do it,
I'm not going to lie, this might be
horrible for me to admit. I was
laughing. I thought it was like just a
crazy moment of just, [laughter] you
know, like whoa, like we're going off or
whatever, right? And I was jumping up
and clapping. So, and I can't pretend
like that wasn't my reaction. I I to to
pretend like I have some sort of moral
uh problem with it would be actually
lying about how I really feel.
>> Yeah. It's not like uh that would be
shock. I wouldn't have been shocked by
that with for Brandon, right? He did
post like that like sneak.
>> I was shocked. I didn't expect him to go
that hard, but I was just like whoa.
Like this is kind of epic. Like
[laughter]
>> these stupid ruin people's lives. They
want to throw all this against [__] Tom
and then cry when like the same level of
heat gets thrown back their way them.
That's how I was actually thinking in
the moment
>> again.
>> Yeah, I understand how you could feel
that way in the moment cuz it's your
friend who got totally wronged. I
understand that emotional response, but
then when you break it down, it's like
personal details. And I think he was
able to reveal personal details that
allowed him to absolve himself and that,
you know, I I feel like he totally won
here until he decided to do something
that I think exposes her identity when
it wasn't exposed before. And well,
if I if I'm not wrong, I believe
>> Well, I believe no,
you could you could convince me of that.
If people come out and disavow Brandon,
do you think there's any chance that
Tom's coming out and going, "Actually,
Brandon, I can't hang out with you
anymore cuz you doxed this person."
>> I'm sure he wasn't offended by it, but I
don't know if like Tom's plan was to be
like, "All right, Brandon, you do the
doxing. I'll do like the legitimate
response." Like maybe that I don't know.
I I get how it looks, but like I just
don't know if that's exactly what
happened.
>> Well, I mean, it would be pretty hard to
know unless you were in the group chat.
Like it would be pretty hard to know if
that was the exact thing, but it's how
it looks. And when there's no disavowel,
it is him kind of saying, "Yeah, like
that's good." You know, I like that.
>> Oh, well, if I was Tom
right now, if I was Tom, I would be
clapping. I'd be like, "Yes, yeah, let's
go." [laughter] Like, how could you not
if you're in that situation, right? Some
just trying to ruin your career with
like heinous lies and [__] like that,
right? I get it sounds like Destiny, but
Destiny's a loser. That's the
difference. So Destiny sucks and Tom is
cool. That's the difference, right?
>> It's totally cringe and Tom's [laughter]
based.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Sometimes it's okay and sometimes it
isn't okay, right? Like come on,
>> dude. If if the excuse is just Destiny
sucks and we're cool, then you guys are
just the same sort of f as Destiny.
Let's be real,
>> I guess.
>> Hey yo, Twitch. Okay. Well, the Twitch
Sorry was here. I assumed you wouldn't
be on Twitch with all I assume it was
already.
>> Jesus Christ, bro.
>> There's no chat on your screen either.
There's no chat on your screen either.
Like, I've got every reason for leaving
on Twitch right now.
>> The no chat is for Twitch, brother.
>> What are you talking about?
>> Whoops.
>> Well, I don't do that [__] so
>> Okay,
>> it's fine. Go off. It's fine.
Yeah, just listen to it's just like it's
gay as hearing this guy be like, "Oh,
no. Actually, it's fine when we do
doxing because uh Brandon Buckingham was
epic."
>> Hey, I didn't do it.
>> Why is he epic? Why is he epic? Cuz he's
Cuz what? Cuz he faked the hospital.
>> Cuz he's suck. That's why.
>> Yeah, but Okay. So, if someone sucks,
you just do them.
>> Okay.
>> Pretty much.
>> No, I mean, I'm joking there. But like
like I don't know. Like in this
situation, I think situations matter.
like context matters to some extent,
right? When Destiny's doxing people,
he's doxing people that are accusing him
rightfully so of, you know, holding like
child porn or whatever of like people
that he's like, you know, uh had
conversations with when they were like
17 and and stuff like that. But then you
have to understand
whether you're right or not.
>> It's no it and it can't be that because
there will be situations like the
Destiny one where not all the proof was
even public and you can't even know like
categorically who's right and who's
wrong. Right? So if he can convince his
audience that he's right then he's just
green lit do like he can green light to
all of them like doxing and just total
>> well I'm not saying it's okay. I'm not
saying it's okay. I'm just explaining
why when I looked at it, I was like,
"This is epic." Like, this is just cool.
>> Well, you're saying you can't pretend
you have you have a moral problem with
it, but it sounds like you're saying an
emotional reason and then just working
backwards and saying, "Actually, my
emotional reason is my moral reason."
>> Well, I just think that it's different
like in certain situations because when
>> Des my friend and
>> No, it's not about being friends. It's
about whether he's right or not. Right.
If if Tom legitimately somebody and
they're just doxing the person accusing
him of that [__] right? And it looks
pretty bad and there's no reason to do
that, then it's bad, right? But if this
is some stupid crazy just saying crazy
lies about him and stuff like that,
right? Why am I supposed to feel upset?
I don't get it.
>> So if someone lies about you, you can
dox So what's the standard? What's the
standard? If someone lies about you can
dox them.
>> I don't think you should dox people. But
I just think it's a different there's a
different like emotional response when
it comes
>> to but there's a rule there's a rule is
we just want the rule
>> right cuz you what you should do listen
>> I I might feel emotional and want to
punch some in the face when she like
talks to me at a bar. Okay. But
emotionally I want to do that
principally punching women in the face
is wrong. So like I have to hold myself
back right. I have to hold back that
emotion and and state my actual or hold
to my actual principle. Just don't do
violence on people cuz they're talking
[__] about you. You know what I'm
saying? Yeah, I get what you're saying.
I don't know. I just Who cares about the
principles? It's just funny. It's funny.
It's funny. It's fine.
>> It's not It's funny when it's like It's
funny.
>> Aren't you a Christian? Aren't you a
Christian or
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, what do you mean you don't
care about the principles? Uh
>> oh.
>> Uh I just I don't know. It's It's I
think it's fine like when are lying
about you.
Yeah. Is that that sounds very Christian
to me, bro?
Isn't Brandon Bakio meant to be one of
these Christian losers, too? Isn't Tom
Pal around with all these like Brandon
Herrera Grifter [__] suckers?
>> By the way,
>> I don't know anything about that.
>> I am almost positive in my mind that uh
Turkey Tom and Tone are hanging out.
That's got to be a thing. Feel like
that's got to be a thing.
>> There's
no What do you mean by that?
>> It's like the same posting. Now, your
skits are posting.
>> No, it's like the same adjacent, right?
It's Brandon Herrera. It's all the the
gun people.
>> Yeah, babe. Bro, Teto's not actually
like friends with those guys. Come on
now.
>> You don't think so?
>> No. No one's friends with Te, bro. Come
on.
>> I Okay.
>> The only people friends with Tone are
like Pegasus and West because they don't
have to actually hang out with them.
They just like online.
>> Those guys [__] suck. Yeah. Okay. I
mean,
I could try to hold you to stuff. I get
what you're saying like emotionally and
I'm like I I understand what you're
saying emotionally but it's basically
>> you don't you don't think like people
should live their lives being like good
people who have like beliefs that they
stand by. You think that's a good thing
to do? Yeah. It's a good thing for you
to do.
>> Yeah, of course they should do that. But
it's like I just think in
>> but not but not when it's like some
nasty on the internet who's telling lies
about your friend. Not not then.
>> I just can't get mad at it, right? Like
I just
>> You don't have to get mad at it. You can
just like recognize, hey, that's wrong.
Brandon Buckingham is like kind of a
piece of
>> It's crazy. I think
>> it's not the first time he's done.
>> I think there's an element to that why I
like it though, right? There's an
element to like, wow, he really just did
that. He did the thing that you're not
supposed to do. Like that is wild and he
did it to like such an unlikable that
has been objectively telling lies about
just me personally along with Tom. I
mean, she's been lied about me on the
forum and too, she's been talking about
how we all deserve to get hit or
whatever, right? When she's the only one
who ends up getting hit, I'm going to
laugh. I'm going to be like, "Wow."
>> Exactly how people justify the Ethan
that are just
>> You want to know great way to not get
Don't go in a [__]
>> That's exactly how people
>> Sorry, I don't feel any sympathy for
these people and they go on the internet
and they say mean things about me and
they don't [__] talk. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Fair enough.
>> Come on, dude. But look, I'm I'm
explaining myself emotionally. I'm
trying to explain to you guys how I
really feel.
>> No, no, no. I I get I'm sorry what
you're saying you feel but it's like
it's just it feels like pulling teeth
trying to get like the the belief the
position the opinion plus just the
feeling you know
>> yeah sometimes you got to just suspend
that just to have a little bit of fun
right like
>> I don't think it's
admitted like very quickly [laughter]
just real quick he admitted very very
quickly that like the principle was
wrong it's just like you should probably
have a better mapping of what you want
to allow versus like what your
principles are. Like you shouldn't say
>> there's commentary and morals and then
there's just real life. You know what I
mean? Like I do think there's like a
little bit of a
Okay. No, this is it's not commentary
morals. It's morals, dude. It's like is
it okay to dox people? Is it okay to go
and post someone's person identifying
information online for the purpose of
directing harassment?
>> My position on docking has always been
there. I don't have a I've never even in
the past like five six years ago if you
were to hear my position on doxing I've
never had the position of it is never
okay to dox people if people are doxing
you I've always been okay with like
counter doxing and stuff like that I've
explicitly said that and stuff like that
if people are going after livelihood and
stuff like that I've always said and you
can pull up clips of this I don't know
where you'd go to find it
>> okay what's your reasoning for being
okay with like counterdoxing then so why
is counterdoxing okay
>> because they set the morals for what
they allow to do to you. So you can
treat those same people, you can just
hold them to their own moral standard.
If they say, "Okay, doxing you is okay."
Then you can be like, "Okay, sure. Let's
live by your worldview. Now I do it to
you." Right.
>> Okay. So if someone like you, it's okay
to rap them back.
>> Yeah.
>> I think Jesus said that, right?
[laughter]
>> I'm pretty sure that's literally what's
in the Bible. They say,
>> "Yeah, you should
>> engage in against people." [laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah,
>> for sure.
>> Well, no. You should have a forgiveness
and you should turn the other way,
right? Obviously.
>> Well, well, that's not what you think,
though, is it? That's not how you live.
And that's not what you think.
>> No, but I don't think that most people
that I encounter are uh are operating
under this like Christian morality,
right? I I I I'm very big on just
treating people like how
>> I just don't I me personally I I don't
really understand the point in just
retribution. Like if there's a you know
I can understand some niche circumstance
>> if somebody's like okay I can do this to
you. It's like okay fair enough.
>> That is retribution. That's retribution.
That's what you're saying.
>> Yeah. I don't have a big issue with
that. To be honest
>> I I have to go back. Okay. That's a
little weird. But I have to go back and
just ask you. You said this commentary
morals versus like real life morals.
That feels really weird to me because
your commentary morals are the ones
you're trying to put on like other
people on the internet. If you're not
willing to live up to those morals, but
you're trying to apply them to other
people, that feels super [__] to me,
right? Like you should live up to
anything you're willing to commentate
on.
>> Those aren't your real life morals.
>> You should be living up to that.
>> You can say it's commentary morals
versus real life morals, but those
aren't your real life morals either.
Let's be serious. You're going to I
guarantee there are a million examples
in real life where you're you're saying
this exact same [__] where you're like,
"Oh, who gives a man? Who gives a man?"
You know? Well, who gives a with doxing
and stuff like that?
>> About like some retributive retributive
act that you'd usually be against if it
wasn't preceded by some wrongdoing that
you think should be punished.
>> Uh,
>> basically when you like somebody, you'll
justify any bad thing they do. Like if
it's somebody you like against somebody
you don't like, you justify essentially
anything.
>> Not not in every case. Obviously, not in
every case, but that there's like a
>> it seems like basically you're just
displaying a blank. just like okay to
>> to like shift really noticeably.
>> I I just think there's like a difference
of perspective. It's like uh to an
extent it's like when it comes to the
perspective of the people around you
when you know the situation more than
like the average person, right? You see
what's going on from the inside, you can
sympathize more with retribution, retri
uh acts of retribution, right? that you
wouldn't necessarily
uh be in support of from the outside
looking in on a different situation with
people that you don't know. So, I think
there's probably some truth to that.
>> Almost call it barbarian retributive
violence, I think. [laughter]
>> Right. Yeah. You're just saying like all
you're just saying there is like yeah,
people have biases and you should just
have your bias and never try and counter
or examine it in any way. It's just
they just basically it it's like saying
yeah it's good to be irrational, right?
>> Um I think a certain level of
irrationality can be suspended when it
comes to your friends because loyalty is
an important value.
>> Okay. But loyalty isn't just like
>> but it depends like what they're doing
like if they're if they're if they're
doing some horrible [__] or they're
scam.
Okay. So you're okay stuff like that,
right? Obviously loyalty is when you're
okay with your friends doing
>> So you're saying loyalty is when you're
okay with your friends doing small bad
things and
>> I think it just depends on a case by
case scenario. You got to look at a
situation. You got to be like, okay, is
this just some is this just my friend or
is this something that I should take
more seriously?
>> Right,
>> dude. I think you displayed a perfect
level of loyalty when you were like,
"Hey, I've seen this stuff that's out on
Tom. I need more proof before I say
anything bad or do anything take any
action against him. I think that was
loyalty. I think other people wanted to
cancel podcast with him, wanted to
distance from him. I think that was a
lack of loyalty, right? Before all the
evidence was in
>> Yeah. Other people.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think I think that was loyalty,
but loyalty shouldn't be.
>> You know, now my my friend has like
obviously conclusively done something
wrong and I'm going to say that it's not
that bad. I think
>> Well, I think it depends on what they're
doing that's wrong. You know, like I
said, if my friends are lying or
scamming people or people over or people
for that matter, obviously
>> people like
>> doxing people.
>> Uh, it depends on the situation, I
think. [laughter]
So why is stealing some from someone
wrong but doxing them isn't like
>> uh you're saying like these things were
like unequivocally doxing you're like
>> stealing I think it's like an inherently
like dishonest action when you're
stealing from somebody whereas with
doxing it could be like justified
>> doxing literally has malicious is like
in the definition of doxing it's like
for the purpose of harassment but you
mean sometimes it's like
>> it doesn't make any sense it doesn't
make any sense You're saying you're
saying you're just saying bias is okay.
Have bias. That's like
>> that's not necessarily what I'm saying.
>> That feels like there's no justifiable.
There definitely would be, but
>> there definitely could be justifiable
doxing. Just don't say that. That's
stupid.
>> Sorry. I'm going to also fall back to
moderating because I don't want Augie to
be 2v1 the whole time. So,
>> sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Go ahead. could do a couple.
>> Now, I just be clear, I'm having a
little bit of a thought experiment here
just to, you know,
>> I figured you basically you basically
Yeah, you you know said,
>> "Oh, I'm okay with it." And now you're
just like, you know, testing the
argument really. But
>> well, cuz I am
>> You basically described how you felt
like how you reacted and then
>> I am describing how I feel and I do have
I did have a reaction like I didn't feel
bad at all when it happened. Right. So I
am talking to you guys a little bit just
to sort of ground me a bit and hear the
other side and stuff like that, right?
Um it is just a bit hard for me to look
at like what these people have done. U
and admittedly it is still one of my
friends. So obviously I'm completely
like ideologically in this whole
conversation because it's Tom, it's one
of my friends, right? So it's like when
I see somebody go after one of my
friends in this dishonest way, right?
And then he is just objectively proving
that everything they've said for the
last two weeks is [__] as they tried
to like terrorize and ruin his life and
destroy his business that he spent the
last whatever decade building and stuff
like that. When I see horrible [__]
happen to them and I celebrate I do want
to explore why I feel that way. So there
is like a little bit of like but I also
do feel that way genuinely. So I don't
know
>> what additional benefit is gained by
doxing them.
>> I think it puts someone to evil. If I
were if I were to play complete devil's
advocate, I do think it puts them on an
uneven playing field, right?
>> How? What do you mean?
>> Because both of them are public figures
now. It's not just an anon versus
that's not quite I understand what
you're sort of saying, but both their
names on the record, I guess you mean?
But like what
>> Okay, I don't know what difference that
quite makes.
>> Mhm.
>> Like what are you aiming to do with
that? What what does that do? Well, she
anything that she says about Tom now,
she has to say that like as a public
person now with like a real identifiable
background. She can't just say whatever
crazy she wants. She has to say that as
her as a person, not just as like some
sort of entity on a website. So, I do
think that that puts things on a more
even playing field. If I were to play
Devil's Advocate,
>> so what so what happens off the back of
that? So, now they're both public
people. What changes for her now? I
think they have the same certain level
of scrutiny around what they say and how
they act online.
Not exactly the same because Tom's like
a public figure.
>> Why?
>> Uh because things that you say can
reflect back on you when you try to live
like a normal life and you have or
you're, you know, going to school,
you're trying to get a job, you're
trying to be a regular person. Like just
like how when Tom dates these crazy and
they can just look up anything that's
happened in his life on KBI farms. It's
the same thing for her, right?
>> So, it does just feel like the goal is
the only the benefit is it damages her
life.
>> Well, it just makes her have to take
into take more seriously what she puts
out on the internet. Right.
>> Well, the damaging stuff is already out
there, so that doesn't we're past that
point.
>> Right. But she can say whatever crazy
she wants as an anonymous person.
Obviously, that holds more weight if
she's like a publicly identifiable
person. Right. Was she really anonymous?
>> But how do our claims hold more weight
now?
>> She was anonymous before
her claims hold more weight because she
has to sort of, you know, be more I
guess she has to be more Look, I'm
playing devil's advocate here, but she
has to be more serious about what she's
saying. She can't just say crazy.
>> But what I'm saying is is that like what
I'm trying to get at is it doesn't seem
like there is really any additional
benefit. The the only thing that happens
here is it damages her life. It's just
like that that's the only goal.
>> And Tom's Tom's already proven his
point. He's already to to any extent
that he can. He has repaired the
reputational damage. The only way he
could maybe go further is by maybe like
trying to sue her for defamation, which
doesn't require doxing. That would just
be, you know, her name would be in the
public filings, but it doesn't require
you posting on Twitter.
>> Yeah. He already knows her identity.
>> Yeah. I don't think it was necessary.
Just to be clear, I don't think it
>> it's not just unnecessary. It's like
there is no additional benefit and it
kind of just makes Tom and his friends
look bad.
>> Yeah, I can definitely see that.
>> It's like so what? This follows her
around in her life. You you never see
that, you know, you're never going to
get to sit there and have the shard and
freer of, you know, not that this would
ever happen, but like imagine her
getting rejected from a job or a college
place or whatever the um because of
this. You never get to see that. It's
just oh, in the moment, yeah, [__] you.
And then then what? you kind of just
look bad anyway.
>> Yeah. I mean, there is some part of me
that's like uh I don't like the fact
that you know there is like an uneven
playing field with public figures where
it's like if you as like an anonymous
person have a bad interaction with a
public figure or perceived bad
interaction. You can just say whatever
crazy [__] you want completely protected
by your own anonymity while this person
has to suffer from the consequences of
what you're saying, what you're putting
onto them forever possibly. Right. So
what do So do you think that commentary
channels, anonymous commentary channels
should be unmasked?
>> No.
>> Why not? Why? They're they're talking
crazy about all these bigger content
creators who have so much to lose.
They've already got their docers out
there.
>> No, I don't think that doxing should be
a normal stand. Just to be clear, like
I'm not saying
>> but but they say but they're making
in a specific context. I think you can't
just look at it as like it's either all
bad or it's all good. You have to look
at the specific situation. teasing out
the what is the rule? What awareness is
it? Okay, it feels like
>> it's it is basically just Well, when
it's one of your friends who has a
girlfriend that wrongs them, then it's
okay. That basically feels like what
your standard is.
>> Well, if it was somebody else that was
wronged by a woman or something, if
Slazo, I know people don't like when
people make references to old commentary
dramas here, but it I'm just saying
>> arguably arguably a response that makes
it sound even worse. So you could go,
>> oh my god, when a woman, it's just like,
okay, so is it just when women do it? Is
it just when women wrong a man? You can
do only women only [laughter]
standard. Yeah, exactly. Men should only
be able to dox women.
>> No, but I'm just saying like um
like I do think you have to look at the
situations like individually and
understand why did this happen? What is
going on here? And you have to determine
was this like not necessarily a
justified use of force or was this an
understandable use of force and then
that can overall in you know uh help you
interpret your opinion on the whole
situation right it's not just all black
or white like all doxing is good all doc
usually to me the the whether some use
of force is justified or whatever is
>> determined or utility by the utility of
what it's going to achieve. If the only
thing you're
>> I think the utility, let's be clear, the
utility here is just to [__] your up.
Let's be honest, right?
>> Yeah. So exposed to PII for the purpose
of like harassment maliciously like to
[__] up, right? For retribution.
>> So it's just doxing with no
justification like
>> Right. I I think that that's true. I
think that that's
>> doxing because I hate this person.
>> Yeah. Not necessarily because I hate
this person, but because she's trying to
ruin my friend's life,
>> which I Yeah, I feel like you just
>> I feel like you probably hate people who
try to ruin your friend's lives with
lies, right? I feel like that's you
maybe you say hate is the wrong word or
something, but
>> it's pretty much like you really dis you
intensely dislike the people who try to
ruin your friends life with um malicious
lies. Right.
>> Right.
>> So, because you intensely dislike them,
doxing them is good. And you well no
>> I didn't say it was good Tom.
>> Maybe I said it was good or I said maybe
I said it was before. I don't think I
said that but I'm
>> or something
>> but I said that I can understand the
human intention behind it. Behind it. I
can understand the human intention
behind it and that when I saw it I
didn't feel bad. That's what I said just
to be clear.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure.
>> Yeah. Um,
man, that's uh that's
>> it feels like we're jumping back and
forth between two different things. So,
you don't So, you don't think it's
justified? You think it's a bad action
or not?
>> I don't personally It's a bad action
like objectively to like dox people um
in this specific situation. I don't It's
hard for me to see it that way. Uh I
gotta be real. Um, I mean, she was, you
know, it seems like she wanted to roll
around in the mud and then she got
exactly what comes with that and now
she's wants to cry about it.
It's hard for me to feel sympathy for
that.
>> This is literally this is the nonsense
argument that I hate where you just
people fall back to doing,
>> oh, I just can't feel sympathy for it's
just like it's not an argument. It's not
an argument. It's not a point. It's not
an opinion. It's not a take. It's just
you like literally saying I don't like
this person so bad thing justified.
That's what that's all it's like the
lamest
>> actually the reasoning for like
>> all bad action basically. It's like
>> yeah
war crimes tons of things is the
justification for all of it. It's like
ultimately comes down to actually these
people just suck. They deserve it.
[laughter]
>> It just feels good.
>> Yeah. Again, I just go back to the Ethan
Klein thing because that to me seems
like so obvious a comparison. It's just
the um like the the lawsuits against
denims where everybody is is justifying
that lawsuits against denims cuz denim
sucks. Denims is cringe. And it's like,
no, this is a guy who's like dox this
person's real identity as suing them,
trying to get them to stop talking about
him. Like that's explicitly the goal
there. And then people will let it go
and they'll be like, you know what,
denim sucks. Denims is cringe. I'm fine
with this. It's like, okay, well I don't
know what what are we supposed to do,
man? Like if you use that justification
that that justifies it just opens all
kinds of crazy. Yeah. No, I see what
you're saying. That's a valid argument.
That's a valid argument. That's worthy
of consideration for me. Definitely. I
see what you're saying there.
Um
um shifting gears. Apparently Nick
implied that you guys knew a bunch of
stuff for ages but played dumb. Still on
that.
>> Like what?
>> So that's not a no.
>> Well, what do you say? So you [laughter]
>> Well, you got to tell me it was
specifically what happened.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh I don't know. I just got a message
saying, "Ask Oie how long he had inside
info from Tom since Dior implied he knew
for a while but played dumb."
>> What do you know?
>> Did you guys know like did you
[laughter] guys know that proven?
>> What's up?
>> I want to know. Did you guys know that
Tom had this all like laid out like that
he was coming back
with like this video? You guys have a
good idea that this was coming out?
Did you get to see like the evidence way
beforehand?
>> Not way beforehand. I saw I did see this
video like a few days ago, I will admit,
but I mean, not like weeks ago.
>> Yeah, it was obvious that Dioro was
baiting on stream the other night.
>> I mean, is that like terrible? I don't
know.
>> I mean, I think it looks super weird
when Dioro immediately jumps to lying
about this girl trying to dox him or
whatever the
>> I mean, you don't think she was fishing
for information? She was trying to speak
to the girl, but that's not Doc saying
Dior is lying about that to try and make
this Brandon Buckingham thing seem okay.
>> She was uh actively looking for that
girl's information though, right?
>> Yeah, but that's not it's not doxing to
go and speak to someone.
>> You don't think she was going to post
that on the on the thread?
>> I have no reason to believe she's going
to post on thread. Why do you think she
was going to do that?
>> Okay.
>> Why do you think she was going to do
that?
>> Cuz she's posting anything else she
could. She'd never post anyone else's
name without their permission as far as
I'm aware. Anyone that said they wanted
to be private was not posted.
>> Like uh like who?
>> She had there were like screenshots
posted that were censored from like
Instagram DMs and
>> I haven't seen her post anyone that was
meant to be private.
>> We also went down this whole line where
it's like totally fine for commentary
channels to post embarrassing
information about people, but they all
avoid posting like identifying
information for a reason, right? It's
like the big big difference. So like
obviously posting docs I you would
assume because she's familiar with these
spaces that she knows that posting docs
is like a red line for a lot of people
and I just haven't seen any indication
>> I [laughter] didn't even well but I
didn't even um well actually for her
probably on Kiwi Farms if I didn't know
this but if what Queen is saying is
correct that she actually censored
identities to not expose people like I
do think
>> I don't know which girl it was I I know
there were DMs that were getting posted
where these girls were reaching out to
people and getting information and there
was someone that didn't want their name
on there or whatever. and they had
scratched it out with black whatever in
the you know screen.
>> Why do you think she was so curious
about who Dior's girlfriend is?
>> She wanted to get more information
>> but not to post it.
>> Was she
said why
>> she's looking for who Tom cheated on her
with at VidCon, right? That's why she
was looking for that.
>> Yeah, she was trying to get She was
trying to get information. She was going
to post
Wait, wait. Wasn't the VidCon girl the
girl that Tom cheated on her with? Was
that the same person? Or am I wrong on
that?
>> No. I I hope Tom didn't cheat on her
with Nick's girlfriend.
>> No, no, no.
>> Tom likes him skinny. So,
>> hold on now. I I The VidCon girl I
assumed was
somebody that Tom had hooked up with
that knew Nick Dioro's girlfriend,
right? Or am I completely getting this
wrong?
>> I I'm not sure about the exact
>> Apparently somebody affiliated with
Destiny or something.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. That was it. They were
trying to figure out who this person
affiliated with Destiny was that um
apparently Dorio's girlfriend would have
known or whatever the apparent Tom
cheated with. But anyway, the point is
there is no indication anywhere in that
thread that she was going to post docks.
Nothing said there indicate she was
going to post dox and Dior comes out the
day this girl is getting doxed lying
about her trying to dox him or is a
girlfriend or whatever. The
that's weird as [__] I have a different
interpretation just by how I know how
Kiwi Farms culture works, but uh I I I
definitely agree that there's no proof
that she was had an intention to dox
her, but I do think that that's probably
what she wanted to do. But I guess
that's just an opinion. I don't know.
>> There's just like no indication of that
at any other point in the post.
>> I mean, she said these people deserve to
get nuked. She was actively looking for
information. Everyone was going to her
release it. They wanted her to release
information to form a bridge or sorry to
form a rift between Dioro and Tom
because if this ex exposed Dior's
girlfriend, Dior would then get to Tom
for allowing this to even happen by just
association, right? They were pushing
her to do that and she was engaging with
those posts. So, it seems like I don't
know. I I could definitely I agree
there's no evidence of it, but like it
definitely seems like that was a strong
motivator. Uh at least in my opinion,
but I don't know.
>> Okay. Why is it so hard? So, in fact,
why do you think the decision was made
in Nick's head to instead of simply say
this girl's weird as harassing people,
trying to harass people I know and get
information out of them to to cause
problems between me and my friends?
She's just involving random offline
people that have nothing to do with it
for no reason. Why did he not just say
that? Why did he instead choose to say,
"She's doxing me. She's trying to dox
me, my girlfriend, whatever."
>> Because he probably felt like that's
what she was trying to do on Kiwi Farms.
>> But that's not substantiated. And the
other thing is
>> Yeah, but I can see how he'd come to
that conclusion. And I know that sounds
>> You really think he came You think he
seriously came to that conclusion? I
>> don't think it's dishonest. Okay,
>> I do believe that.
>> Well, I I guess you know,
>> like, let me see the post that she was
saying. She told me the girl was
apparently a long-term girlfriend he had
known since elementary school. So, she's
dropping like little details. All these
freaks and the ones covering for him
deserve to get nuked. She's responded to
somebody telling her.
>> But is that Hold on. Is that information
that wasn't out before? I could have
sworn I'd heard that before and I don't
know where information from
>> the that went to elementary school that
Nick was like with somebody who's like
that that was his girlfriend at VidCon.
People speculated and that people knew
that he'd been
saying just my friend.
>> I know it sounds crazy. I don't know
anything about Nick Dioro's girlfriend.
So I don't know like how long they were
dating.
>> I just could have sworn I'd heard that
before and I but I don't know if I'm
just like made that up. It's maybe I'm
getting deja vu from something else.
>> I don't I don't remember about that. So,
I like I've got my eye.
>> I'll go deja vu for now.
>> Sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I do
think Yeah. It's just um
>> Yeah. I don't think that's an honest
conclusion, Nick Drew. I really don't. I
think um you know, I don't if you
honestly believe it.
>> I actually don't know why this person in
the thread said it. The person in the
thread that says like, "Oh, you're just
going to dox people." And this this was
like where somebody in the thread said,
"You're doxing people." He said,
"Apparently a long-term girlfriend. He's
known since elementary school." I unless
you want to say that's the doxing.
Somebody accuses her in the thread and
that doesn't make sense to me either. I
don't know.
>> Yeah, it's just a self victimization
thing trying to equivocate and Nick
knows that
>> that's real close to getting her docks.
Oh, do people like know where Nick went
to school or something?
He's on Aiden's stream by the way.
>> Is that That's where we've gotten to.
Nick is now going on stream.
>> Nick called. He really does look wer.
[laughter] He really does lookers now.
Damn, he's fully embracing.
>> Okay, another reason why I'm on Aiden's
stream is he what?
>> Here's another reason why I'm pro. This
is another reason why I changed my
position on doxing is because you guys
turned on my friend Aiden and I think
Aiden was cool for doxing.
>> You guys bullied him out of the
community. [laughter]
>> We didn't bully him out at all. I talked
to him like two days ago.
>> We backstabbed him in London. That's
what you said. We all backstabbed. Even
though I've literally tried I've tried
so hard.
>> Your stream is brutal against him, dude.
Like, come [laughter] on.
>> I I understand. Look, that's how I talk.
That's how I talk. [gasps]
>> Yeah, maybe it's a British
retribution for Aiden leaking things
about him. Queen was like retributively.
>> To be fair, I don't even anything. I I
leak like, "Oh, he has bad table
manners. Oh, we fuck."
>> No, all I remember was I watched that
stream. I was in the chat engaging with
it. I thought it was hilarious. And then
the longer that it went on, the more I
was like, "Oh, is this like aen stream?
I don't even know where I am right now."
>> I was just uh I was, you know, we're
making content.
>> Yeah, true.
>> We're recouping costs from that weekend,
bro.
>> Well, wait. If Nick's on Aiden, like,
can we watch that? Like,
>> I think he's off now.
>> Threw it up on stream or anything. You
know,
>> I didn't see where he was on.
>> I think they were just talking about tag
time. It doesn't look I don't know.
>> Oh, okay. Unfortunate. Too bad. I see
tech.
>> We could just get Nick in here. We could
just hash this all out right now. We
could just wanted to join up on the
stream. We could hash this all out right
now.
>> Would be totally fine with it.
>> You know, when I have a disagreement
with someone, I like to just, you know,
talk to them about it and really get
down to exactly what's going on. That's
me personally.
>> Someone says all can just say what you
want with your chest. I mean, I feel
like I am I say what I want or I say how
I feel honestly to my own detriment.
Like that's what
>> I don't think you said anything that's
like uh you know
>> yeah dishonest. I feel like you're
you're literally owning the position
that you even slightly disagree with
logically in your head and just be like
this is how I feel though and I don't
know why I feel that way.
>> Well the way that I come to my own
conclusions with things is I just say
how I feel and then I talk with people
about it and then I come up with a more
fortified conclusion afterwards. So
that's what I'm doing with you guys
right now because you guys will push me
on. So
>> yeah, fair enough. All right, let's um
Dude, why can someone Where's Hellbent?
Hellbent is the only channel of
communication we have now.
>> Only got to ask this only
>> tell Hellbent. Uh no, actually actually
technically Aiden's asked that quite a
few times trying to avoid. Okay, so
>> all right, we we just need Hellbent to
get a message to Nicholas Dioro right
now. Tell him to hop on the stream.
Although he might be streaming, too.
He's definitely not going to do that. If
he's live, there's no way he'll talk to
us.
>> I go cross stream. [laughter]
>> Yeah, he No, he won't do that. He would
never He would never want us on stream
with him while he's talking to his
audience. Now he's definitely live
still.
>> I got to be careful. He's still live.
>> I'm on dangerous ground right now. I've
lost my Tommy C connection last time I
called.
>> Yeah, that's that's tough. That sucks,
man. That's
>> that's a rough one, man.
>> I've been crying all night.
>> That's you you're you're in trouble now.
Okay. I heard that guy took out Chudlo
Logic. I think you're next.
>> Yeah. Uh Tommy took Chud down to the
below 1k tier. It was it was a brutal
decimation. [laughter]
It's very very rough, man.
Um
has has Chud is Chud even looking at
this stuff? Chud went on vacation. Okay.
Did Did they wait for Chud to go on
vacation to drop this? By the way, what
do you think, Kaggi? What do you think
of that conspiracy theory
>> that Tom W
on his way to Vietnam?
>> He was very quick to accuse me of
sweeping. Uh-oh. [laughter]
>> Allegedly.
>> Wait, what did he think you were
sweeping by doing?
>> No, I'm just trolling. He I I do believe
that he was more calling out Nick
>> when I look back on that. Uh, but he was
definitely very like he's like, "Oh, I
hope Augie streams about this. I better
hope he's not blah blah blah."
>> Yeah, but it felt very tongue and cheek
with you. It felt very, you know, it
wasn't like
>> Well, I was bantering with him in the
DM. I don't give a [__] Like I I was
>> I just you know I don't know if you saw
what I was talking about but obviously
you know it seemed totally like the big
>> I did watch your coverage. I did watch
your coverage of our conversation. I
agreed with that. So
>> awesome. Awesome.
>> Look at Nick's stream title. Uh okay.
Turkey Tom responded. We are so back.
Why is no one else covering this? O
[laughter] I think
he's been go openly going after Chud on
this stream by the way. Ooh,
>> I did hear there was he did.
>> How do you How do you do that when
you're like too get in the call? I just
like don't understand why he even gets
off like taking shots if he's like too
actually hash any of it out. Is that the
same [__] that Willie Mac does?
>> Wow, that definitely wasn't for me. But
yeah. Okay, I agree with that. I I do
think
>> Wait, was that Sorry, was that for me?
Like am I supposed to answer
>> supposedly for you? I think you
>> Oh, I mean I
said we should get
>> I am very pro talking to people. I'm
very pro debate. That's why I'm here
right now. I mean I'm very
>> I I uh if I had things my way, if I was
the content god, I would control all the
debates. So I mean
>> I tried to get Willie Mack to debate
Queen last summer. That's what started
to form my bridge with Willie Mack. So,
I mean, I don't answer for Nick. He can
do it. He can do whatever he wants. I
don't really answer for him.
>> Yeah. I don't
I I just don't understand how anybody's
still standing with Willy M guy. This
guy sucks. Okay. Especially if you're
going to stand behind the the like
doxing by
Brandon Buckingham. It's like, oh,
doxing wasn't even a problem for you
guys. So, there's like literally no
reason for that video to have been made.
Dude, I'm literally so I'm so excited to
see where Willie M goes with his
content. So stop sort of dying down. I
literally like he's had two flop videos
on Candace Owens.
>> Not the Candace. It's not the Candace
stuff.
>> Yeah, exactly. Two flop videos on
Candace Owens and that over anyway. So
like what's next? What's next? I would
love Here's what I would love. I would
for start doing a series of videos on
Fuentes and start fighting with Gropers.
That would just
>> bring bring a smile to my face.
[laughter] Nothing else.
>> Holy [__] That would be so good. He
that would actually make sense, too,
because he does take shots at Fuentes
regular.
>> He goes after anyone going after the
Yeah.
>> Well, yeah. Well, he also does these
like low IQ arguments. He's like, "Is
Fuentes gay?" It's like I understand
like people think Fuentes is gay, but
like when I see Willie Mack make those
kinds of arguments, it just comes across
as so low IQ and just lowlevel
engagement with anything Fuentes has to
say. Like obviously I think we all know
if Fuentes got into a call with Willie
Mack, he would just run circles around
that guy mentally. So
>> I mean Hassan did.
>> I don't think I ever watched Hassan
Willie go at it. Actually,
>> you should you should give it a go one
day. It's funny. It's so funny.
>> I think I was off the internet at that
point.
Did he get uh he got raped?
>> He goes on and Hassan's like he's just
released a video on Hassan and Hassan
calls him on to his stream and he's like
let's debate and he's like Willie what
what points what criticisms do you have
for me? And Willy's like oh I don't know
I have to check my video
>> Auggie. Did you feel like Chud was
accusing you of not condemning Tom?
>> Yeah. So I was just asking you what did
you think Chud was cuz when Chud was
complaining about people Yeah. You're
not echoing anymore. when he was
complaining about people, I got the
impression he was saying people are
acting like this didn't happen when it's
like massive drama and you should just
cover it and put your opinion on the
record. That's the impression I got. Did
you get a different impression?
>> How is this? I'm just testing. Oh,
sorry, sorry, sorry.
>> When it comes to Chud or whatever,
right? I did get the impression he was
doing a little bit of like a cabal call
out initially, right? Because
historically, I mean, everyone knows
there's been past drama around Tom that,
you know, we didn't cover and stuff like
that, right? And that that kind of like
built this sort of reputation, this idea
that any negative story that happens
around Turkey Tom will just go ignored
and undisussed by the community because
we have some sort of like financial
contract with Turkey Tom, right? I did
kind of feel like Chud was playing into
that. Looking back on it though, I think
it was more so a call out at Nick rather
than me. Uh just because I'm so like,
you know, distant from this whole scene.
I mean, I I check in from time to time,
but you know, I I kind of I'm a little
bit on a different path right now,
right? So, like I do think that it was
kind of a distant call out. It was more
of a call out on Nick, but I do I did
see him in the Discord. He was getting
very antsy about sweeping and he was
like, "It's all going to be going to
cover this blah blah blah." I think he
was applying a little bit of pressure on
me to cover it, which I mean, I found to
be ridiculous because of course I was
going to cover it.
>> Okay. But the impression I've been
getting is that people think Chud was
saying that this is like a big deal and
Tom's guilty so you have to cover this.
But I never got that impression once
that he was like, "Oh, Tom's very
guilty. This proves he's like a you have
to cover this, but you're not going to
cuz you're sweeping." I think it was
like it's embarrassing for Tom. So I
hope you do cover it because hugely
important.
>> I I agree with that. But like if Chud is
if his opinion of the allegations was
this was a nothing burger, but he's at
the same time outraged and nobody's
covering it.
>> That does kind of feel weird to me.
>> Well, it's not a nothing burger no
matter what because the information is
like embarrassing and and like
sensational and it's like it's it's
content at the end of the day. It's like
it is great content whether it's whether
the extremities whether the actual
things you would condemn or not are
true, right?
>> Yeah. And it's even better content now
that Tom like refuted everything. Right.
Tom came out and just like blew out this
allegation in a way nobody has in years.
I can't remember the last time somebody
blew out an allegation like this, right?
>> It's like George not found here. It's
like George not found here sort of sort
of allegation, right? I'd say
>> I think it might be even stronger than
that,
>> but yeah, it is.
>> Let me ask you guys this question cuz
this is like a little bit of a thing
I've been like also doing a little bit
of thought experimentation with. So, do
content creators have an obligation to
humiliate and make fun of their friends?
Like if their friends are in drama and
it's not severe,
>> no,
>> but it's also embarrassing, right? Do
they have an obligation to just make fun
of and humiliate their friends on their
own platform?
>> If if your whole thing is humiliating,
embarrassing other people, then I think
generally it's good practice to to, you
know, apply that evenly.
>> But even your own friends, like why
can't you just be like, I like making
fun of people that I hate and that I
don't like. Why can't you draw a
distinction between that and your
friends? Just like a human being.
>> You can. And if you want if you want
your stream to be like, you know, here's
I just sit here and talk about the
people I I hate, then then sure. But
there are some people like like Nick who
like to sort of build themselves like
the drama news show and they very
clearly sort of see themselves that way
or like Tom, you know, kind of sees
himself like a journalist. you know, he
he very clearly kind of takes him views
himself that way and he's gone after
people like West Jeep before for stories
up and and they all do that. They all go
after people for stories up, being
inconsistent with their friends or, you
know, uh sweeping when well one of these
lefties has a friend doing something
embarrassing, whatever the I do agree
like if your friend is like hurting
people, scamming people, lying, whatever
the [__] right? You should call them
out. If you're not going to call them
out for doing stuff like that, then you
know you're a loser. But if your friend
just had an embarrassing moment, like he
had like a cringy breakup with a girl or
there was some weird like relationship
drama or just something cringy that
happened that isn't like breaking news,
like they didn't do anything wrong or
bad, but it is like humiliating and
funny. Do the friends of these people
have to cover stuff like that
>> or can they get away with not covering
it because they're just like, you know
what, I just don't want to humiliate my
friends. Like, I like these people.
>> I think it's difficult because the
condemnation and the humiliation from
>> especially people like Nick and Tom is
so similar, if you know what I mean. I
This looks really bad, dude. This looks
really bad. That's like a Nick stream.
That's and so the condemnation, the
humiliation are like the same thing in
in this content.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. I don't think you have a reason
that you have to cover it. I personally
think you just go, I know this person
too much or I'm too close to this
person. I can't even cover it fairly, so
I'm not going to. I think you do that. I
think as long as you don't downplay,
right?
>> You like can do that. You can do that.
I'm saying like why would I would you
like
>> just speaking just speaking clearly or
whatever right
>> best practices
>> the initial the original Tom drama which
was like the Kai like Liam thing or
whatever right I never covered that and
Tom never asked me it's not like he
never you know he never asked me like
don't cover this or whatever right I
made my own conscious decision not to
cover that because it was just I what I
looked at it as was just cringy
relationship drama between him and
another YouTuber and I didn't want to
get involved in that right this new
recent stuff like the allegations that
came out against him by these girls.
When these allegations first dropped,
the first thing I did was I, you know, I
I called Dior and I was like, "We have
to cover this. Like, this cannot be
uncovered otherwise it's just going to
look too bad." You know what I mean?
Like, we have to review this honestly.
Um, so I think there's a difference
between these two types of stories, but
is that like a fair take or is that
cucked? I think it's I'm just like I'm
not 100% sure what your standards have
been. I just know what I've seen of
Nick. So I don't know. It sounds fair
enough. It could be fair enough, but it
just depends how you've sort of acted
because the it just is like so much Nick
like same thing with like so we had this
argument like 5 minutes ago where it's
like um you start talking about oh I
don't feel bad for these people.
something Nick says all the time. And
then the the other one is this looks so
bad. And when the whole stream every day
is just these emotional arguments that
aren't actually condemnations, but a
phrase like condemnations,
how do you draw the line between your
friend doing something humiliating,
that's bad optics, and your friend doing
something condemnable in terms of like
applying standards evenly? Because your
condemnation is just saying this looks
bad, you look stupid right now, whatever
the [__]
>> Mhm.
That's all Nick's capable of doing.
That's all he ever does.
Oh,
>> you're back open, Quan. You're like
opening up again. Reverb a little bit.
>> Guys, I'm in my stream or just on J
Stokes.
>> I'm guessing you don't you have a noise
gate on OBS, but you don't have a noise
gate here.
>> I don't have a noise gate in OBS.
>> I do have a noise gate here. That's why
I'm
>> Well, slightly confused cuz no one's
mentioning it there.
>> Augie, do you have any response to that?
No, I I take
>> I I take into account like what you're
saying about like the emotional
arguments. I I do feel like uh I feel
like what I want to say is like there is
some level like do you live your life
rigidly by your standards and your
principles or do you acknowledge that
certain situations are different and
there's context and there's human
emotions and these things are valuable
not necessarily by just your rigid view
of like standards and morals and ethics
cuz it seems like Would you It's like I
can understand. It's like I I can just
separate those things out, right? What
is my principle? Can I understand where
this person's coming from when they
break their principle or is it just like
totally irrational? You know, there are
you can just pass these things out.
>> Like, could you see your friend doing
something that is
logically or morally wrong, but you can
sit back and just be like, "That was
kind of awesome and funny, and I'm
you're my friend, and you're my guy, and
I support you anyway." Are you ever in
positions like that where you can act
like that or are you always the person
who's like, "Nope, this is strictly
against my code of ethics."
>> I I don't know. I just I just don't know
what you're asking. There are other
times where
>> So I
>> I'm like I get likeis out of something.
Yeah, I express cases of bad things
happening sometimes,
>> but I would still say it's wrong. You
know, it's I'm not gonna sit there and
act like
>> I'm just like I'm asking you kind of
like a philosophical
question. You can feel like this person.
I feel kind of good when this happens.
Why is
>> you have to ask what happens when you
feel like somebody's done something
wrong? What do you do when somebody's
done something wrong? Because for Quean,
I think for for you guys, like if Tom
had done age play, a bunch of you guys
were going to cut him off, right? For
Quean, I think he wouldn't have cut off.
wouldn't have cut Tom off for that. He
would never have like hidden that,
right? That's the way he looks at it.
But when you have like bad people,
people who have done bad things, how are
you going to react personally? And I
think a problem with some of the
commentary people is they've created
this standard where when they somebody
does a bad thing, we need to kick them
out of the community. We need to cut
them off. We can't be associated with
them anymore. Right? I think that's
probably the difference here is you you
feel like when we're saying this is
really bad, you might be hearing us
saying you have to cut branded bucking
them off. You should never
professionally associate with them
again. I do feel like there's like a lot
of like
>> That's true.
>> I Yeah, I do feel like a lot of pressure
of like cuz in commentary that's kind of
how it works. It's like if somebody does
bad thing, you cut them off and stuff
like that. And I feel like if it's if it
really works that way, then commentary
has a lot of really old and outdated
moral standards that kind of need a lot
more nuance and perspective so that we
don't just cut people off whenever they
do something that's bad, but we have
more of like a human conversation around
it and just be like, okay, you know,
let's look at the what's going on around
here, you know? Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I think the I think that's where
like a lot of the issues are coming from
is like we can't even have an honest
>> conversation commentary has too much of
a rigid
>> yeah I I think we have too much of a
rigid view on like a lot of things such
as doxing or even other subjects right
like you even mentioned like the age
plan stuff like that maybe you know
maybe there is more there's like a rigid
view on like
>> any individual thing it's the rigid view
is like if someone does something bad.
You can't be associated with them versus
>> like simply being able to be associated
with someone like like I'm against
doxing in all cases, but if Aiden's like
doxing people, I'm not going to cut him
off. I'm going to say Aiden's a doxer.
That's bad. You know that it's like that
>> that [clears throat] simple. But make
jokes about
>> Yeah. But I feel like there's like a big
expectation with this community where
it's like how could you align yourself
or be around people that do things that
you consider as like grave moral sins?
>> Yeah.
I I agree. Yeah,
>> that's the problem.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But that's like a it's not
about any of the specific um topics like
it's not about a having too rigid of a
stand on doxy or having too rigid a
stand on age play. The too rigid part is
this more core thing that is like
everything has to be nuclear. Everything
has to be a cut off. And I don't even
think that's like a standard that other
people are imposing. I think that's a
standard that is like self-imposed where
you're bas where people are just being
like, "Oh, well, I don't want to get
>> it feels like it's a standard that's
almost uh put on largely by the chat
because the chat wants blood. The chat
wants violence. They want more.
>> Some chats are always going to want no
but I think that that logic it starts
from the chat and then the creators look
at the chat. They're like, "Oh, my chat
wants war with this person. I'm against
this certain thing. Somebody I know is
doing thing. I must go to war with them.
And so then that creates like this rigid
moral standard that realistically nobody
can appeal to because everybody is up
and they're going to do things from time
to time. They're going to have
>> You're blaming you're blaming the chat,
but the chat's always going to be that.
>> I'm not blaming the chat, but I'm I
think that that's where the symptom
starts.
>> Sure. Sure. But but ultimately it's on
the creator because you have to just not
be aud
I I I understand that
and like I just think if you disavow
somebody, like if you disavow something
someone's done, does that mean you can't
ever talk to them anymore? Cuz like I
>> I don't think so.
>> I just don't see it that way.
>> I I think as long as you're willing to
like never hide the thing they've done,
like as long as you're willing to talk
about it openly, somebody makes that
criticism of them, you don't like sweep
for them in that instance, right, then I
I just don't think you necessarily have
to cut that person off. I don't think
that's necessarily the solution every
time. Depends on what it was, right?
>> Yeah. But then if people do up things
and you don't even cut them off and
you're just like ah that person did a
wrong thing. It's like do they get the
appropriate level of justice or
punishment for doing the thing that's is
a big moral crime in the community. Then
there creates a new problem where it's
like people aren't subjected to enough
punishment for doing the things that are
supposed to be like grave moral sense.
So it's like then you have to go back to
cutting them off fully to sort of
satisfy that need of punishment.
>> I can I can throw up this video here.
This is apparently um the Dioro segment
that where he's talking about um
commentary and [__]
>> You guys want to give this a look?
>> Oh my god.
>> Let's give it a look.
>> Well, that's where we're at here with
the two girls.
>> Um one, thanks for doxing me, Tom.
>> Oh, hold on. I heard somebody join. You
guys are both in.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> All right.
>> Thanks for sending his pictures to the
owner of Kiwi Farm. Look, I I don't
know. I did my best to censor it. It
obviously did not work. My bad. Uh, I
also wouldn't have posted the thing that
Brandon Buckingham posted, but I'm not
shedding a single tear for this wretched
[__] And I'll explain why in a minute.
>> Wow.
>> Uh, but I'll let that sit for a second.
Also, [snorts] I wasn't bleeding because
of my period. And you know damn well. I
told you I liked it cuz I gave in to you
hitting me in the face. You're Tom.
You're a So, that's that. Um, and then I
saw this one which actually triggered
the out of me. I'll admit it.
>> Oh, sorry. This is him talking about the
whole doxing situation, not just the
conversation.
>> I triggered when I saw uh Gunt Super
Soldier said, "Are you going to address
anything either?" And then and then she
goes, "We're going to make a statement
once we both have watched the video and
collected our thoughts."
No, you don't. No. No. No. No. I'm
sorry. No. I'm I'm doing like a What is
it? The 24 frames of Nick. Like, no. You
don't get to do that.
You don't get to do that. No, you don't
get to sit here and wait while you're
live posting and raging in the Kiwi
Farms thread crashing out. I didn't get
to. My friends didn't get to. We got dog
piled.
>> Can you put this fat 1.25, please? I
This is
>> You psychotic [__] By you. You don't
get a break. What are you talking about?
Answer now. Oh, no. No. No. We're
talking now. You can talk now. You don't
get a break.
We're looking for tips on how to get you
on the stream, Nick. Just come have a
conversation.
Welcome to the stream. We're just
reviewing this. We're taking a look. If
we could have this conversation with you
directly, we wouldn't have to review
your stream. We're totally good with
that. I'm good with that. I'll even I'll
even set Quimma to like 50% volume.
Okay.
>> We need to cover this right now. Funny
thing I saw today is that
>> apparently
[__] I'm gonna just kill this for a
second while I'm explaining this and
we'll do it for a second. Apparently, if
I waited just a little bit longer, a
full video would have come out that we
could have just gone through, but now I
have to do more work. Apparently, that
was 8 am on Thursday morning. Oh,
Thursday morning. It was 8:00 a.m. on
Thursday morning. That was the If you
got in past 8 a.m. on Thursday morning
after the stuff dropped on Wednesday
night, you were a sweeper. So, we're
already getting the brooms out. We're
sweeping hard. If you didn't get in in
the first like 15 hours, you
>> That's Kathy. I don't think that's
Kathy. Maybe. Maybe it's Kathy.
>> That's like crazy. It's Jover. But
>> I don't think so. Let me check. If he's
got the VIP badge, it's not Kathy.
That's the person. And I I'm pretty sure
that's the name that was here before.
Give me a second. I'll check.
>> You're going to get right.
>> You get right.
>> Kathy
Kathy,
>> just giving you my honest. I'm like
crazy compromised on this topic. I have
absolutely no problem saying it. I'm
>> Yeah, you came into chat just now. Did
you not hear me read the message or I
talked about the message?
>> I didn't really know what you were what
you were doing to be honest. I was I was
back and forth.
>> Yeah.
>> You
was uh uh gummy verse. Thank you for the
gifted sub to Nick. Are you guys looking
for tips on how to find to find how to
attract viewers to your show? That was
the message he sent.
>> Dude, debate purple.
>> I do like the
>> I do like the um that's very destiny
coded. Very interesting.
come through a comment.
>> He does. That is what Stevie does. That
is what Stevie does. He comes into chat
like that.
>> Very unfortunate. Very unfortunate.
>> I do not want my friend to come out of
this looking like a domestic abusing.
I'm more compromised than I was when I
made this stream. And it's not because I
know that she's a lying piece of It's
not that I know her friend's a lying
piece of It's that while they were
lying, while they were doing this, while
this was happening, okay, thank you for
doxing me, Tom. While all of this was
going on, while I'm getting people on
Twitter saying that I've stabbed Tom in
the back when Tom's totally on my side
with us, or I'm getting people from this
community coming and telling me that
I've been sweeping for my night friend
or something. All while that's
happening, this psychotic wretched
is trying to dox people in my personal
life because I know him.
>> I Yeah, I don't see that.
>> He's literally incapable of insulting
women without sounding like a total is
so funny. [laughter]
>> Whoa.
Why? Whack.
>> Uh,
wait. I I will say
at least for me, I don't know about you,
Queen. I said he responded in a
perfectly reasonable amount of time, and
it didn't seem like his coverage was
sweeping to me. He basically covered it.
I didn't need him to like come out. I
actually I think the only comment I had
was, "Oh, weren't you guys friends for
like 10 years? If this guy's got like a
fetish in his personal life that he's
never like made public in any way,
you're going to cut him off for that?
That seems really excessive to me." That
was That was all I said about it. I
don't know. Did you have a Do you think
he was sweeping?
>> Yeah. No, I said I said Nick's coverage
was too boring to watch cuz he wasn't
sweeping.
>> Oh, okay. Well, I I don't know. I just I
guess is it the the pre- sweep
allegations from Chud saying like,
"Don't sweep this guys. You got to cover
it."
>> Yeah, he's he is just lashing out Chard,
but obviously he's an avoidant
estrogenic person, so he's not going to
sit there and just talk at length about
his issues with Chard or make an
argument. He'll never go on stream with
Chard. Well, he might. Apparently, he
talks apparently he talks a little bit
more about it at some point.
>> I don't I don't believe
I believe every second.
>> Yeah, I'm not even kidding you. There
was a manhunt for a person I attended
VidCon with just because I'm friends
with Tom.
Yeah. No, I'm ser this has been
deranged. This is absolutely ridiculous.
Turkey Tom's ex attempted to dox an
offline person that I
>> again I I that's an insane that's insane
hyperbole right [laughter] there. That's
pretty absurd hyperbole. I
think this sucks.
This sucks because I think
I think he probably discussed this with
people and it probably should have been
pointed out like, "Hey, I I don't know
if I could go that quite that far." It's
I do feel like this is being spoken
about this way to make it make sense
that this person got docked too. That is
the impression I get from this.
>> Attended VidCon with in 2025.
This was done because quote unquote she
must have known something and she wanted
us to suffer for simply
>> you cannot.
>> Wait, is he still there's he still
typing in chat? There's no way
situation. is still typing chat. Bro,
>> get on the stream. Get on the stream,
you fat.
>> Is this for me? I'll I'll, by the way,
I'll totally drop I'll drop back the
moderating like I did with Auggie and
Queen earlier. I don't have to I don't
have to take a side on this. I just want
the content. We all just want to have
the conversation.
>> Yeah, just go and lay out your argument.
I understand, Nick. It's difficult for
you. We get it. We get it. making making
any kind of coherent point is difficult
for the American Italian mind. The [__]
mind, the guinea mind struggles you I
mean I don't want fentes slander on the
stream if you could just chill a little
bit. It's really rude actually.
We we literally will get you in here,
Nick. It's totally fine. It's totally
fine. We're good. Augie, you're also
muted, by the way. I don't know if
that's intentional or not. Just letting
you know.
>> That's intentional. That's intentional.
>> No, listen. I got nothing to say. You
guys are in a beef dig. I'm not going to
defend Nick or attack Nick. I'm just
sitting here in the
>> You guys are making it weird. It's my
friend. I just Sorry. I I I understand.
It's totally fine if you're not saying
anything. I just wasn't sure cuz you
weren't responding earlier either. I get
it. No, I don't need you. Listen, I'm
not going to tell you. I'm not going to
attack him either.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I told you. I'm totally fine with
that.
[laughter]
>> Okay. Okay.
>> It's fine. That's fine. It's fine. I
know how you guys work. You guys,
>> I'm not I you just weren't comment on
like the video either. You wanted to
watch it. So I was like,
[laughter]
>> well, you wanted to watch it with us, so
I was like, maybe he just muted for a
second, but then Nick was in the chat,
so I get it.
>> You're right. [laughter]
>> Yeah, I get it. Okay, okay.
>> And then Nick came in the chat. It's
like you get caught with your pants down
like
>> Yeah, [laughter] yeah, yeah, sure, sure,
sure, sure. I get it. Yeah.
>> Yeah, shut the up.
>> Yeah, he gets very sensitive about stuff
like this. I know you he doesn't like
people hanging out with the wrong
people.
about stuff behind the scenes as far as
I'm understand.
>> Come on.
>> Well, that's true, isn't it? That's
true.
>> No, let's keep playing. Let's listen.
>> This worthless gets no sympathy from me.
She was telling everybody I sh you not.
She was telling everybody that she ran
to Kiwi Farms to protect women. Her her
goal was to run to a manpopulated forum,
a doxing website, to smear my friend as
a
wifebeating
to save women.
Okay. I there are hints in in those
directions. I'll give them I'll give him
that. I don't think she said those
things were categorical or I don't think
she said most of those things
categorically, but All right.
I I don't know why you can't just say
this is like borderline harassing me
reaching out to people in my personal
life trying to dig for information.
That's like you can just say that that's
bad. That's condemnable. We can all say
this is crazy. But the lie about doxing
is obviously motivated. It's obviously
for a reason.
>> Yeah. And I by the wayh how would you
put this? like she wants to ask a
question and you could say that it's
inappropriate for her to go ask this
question or something, but it seems like
the information she wants is not
information to publish to hurt Nick or
to expose this person. It's literally
like Tom cheated on me. I just want to
know who he cheated on me with.
>> I think she'd publish it. She'd
obviously publish information she found.
That's what she'd been doing in the
first.
>> No, she published she publish cheated
with,
>> but I don't think she'd publish Nick's
anonymous.
>> No. Yeah. Yeah. I agree with you on
that. Yes. I don't think she'd probably
if it's like a content creator that that
Tom's cheated with, she talk about that.
>> She would say who it is.
>> She would reach she would reach out
to the person. Yeah. I don't there's no
reason why we should dog his girlfriend.
I think if it was a content creator that
Tom cheated with almost definitely post
it. I think otherwise she's basically
going to reach out. I I don't think as
far as I understand the other
screenshots with testimony have names
blacked out. That's as far as I'm aware
from.
>> I'm just curious like what like why do
you think she would protect Dioro's
girlfriend?
>> I just haven't seen any evidence that
it's not about whether she'd protect I
haven't seen any evidence that she would
take the aggressive action of Docs and
Dora's girlfriend in the screenshots.
>> Understand it. So, she's only going
after people that relate to Tom.
>> She's all she's been publishing is
information about Tom. And if someone
has said they're okay with the name
being there, their name's there. But as
far as I know, she hasn't just outed
people's names or anything like that. As
far as I'm aware. Okay. So,
>> um that I mean that's basically what I'm
saying is I I've not seen an indication
that she doesn't understand doxing.
She's been online a lot. So, I feel like
she understands the difference between
publishing personal messages you have
and doxing somebody directly.
>> Okay.
>> On timer, I think you guys are plenty
good on the timer, just so you know.
>> Yo, pull this up. I just DMD this
>> being sent this. Okay.
>> I just got sent this.
>> Let's see here.
Okay. When is this from? Thursday 11. Is
this
Is this new? This might be a new message
she's throwing out here. I'm not totally
sure.
>> I don't think this is new. This is old.
>> This th
right Jesus. I'm I'm I'm struggling with
days right now.
>> Okay. While I'm not going to hit the gas
and the blood lust here, I think it's
very fair to make clear, by giving us
this girl's name, you'll likely destroy
any goodwill Nick has for Tom and by
extension anyone loyal to Nick and
significant impact significantly impact
fat boy. Do this only if you're certain.
Personally, I'll find it funny as hell.
Turkey Tom does not redeem apparently.
I don't know if you've noticed, but I've
been going gorilla mode on Tom since
I've got hard since I got hard proof he
was cheating on me and his friends were
clearly all complicit in his degenerate
freak behaviors. So, at this point, I
don't really care. Sorry, Josh. I know
you're probably mad at me.
>> Oh, yeah. I can see how you implication
to to dogs more so more strongly than
the ones you posted before
>> by giving us this girl's name. So, hold
on. Who is this girl in this case? That
is I'm not totally sure who the object
of this post is girl.
>> If it is Nick's girlfriend, if it's
Well, I need this guy. Can we go back?
>> This post, I will say this po this guy
that she's responding to, this is
somebody that like viciously hates me
and Nick on the thread and has been
trying to get her to attack me and Nick
consistently throughout the entire
situation. So
>> yeah, who is this? Who is he? Who is she
threat? I just need to know the object.
>> I would assume Dioro's girlfriend, but I
mean,
>> well, so there's one person that we said
she'd say.
>> I suppose we could go to the
>> the person she cheated with.
>> And then
>> let me pull up the original link
>> because if it would destroy any goodwill
Nick has for Tom, I would say
this person's in any case. I don't see
how they could make this calculation if
it was Nick's girlfriend getting doxed.
To be fair, when I started covering
this, I asked for all of the
information. I'm like, "Okay, just show
me any evidence that she's um like shown
any proclivity for this." And we went
through the other two posts which don't
show any proclivity for this.
So, hold on. Let me go trying to find
specifically the other post. I haven't
seen this post on Twitter. So, this is
like uh I remember seeing this when I
was reading a thread live, but I haven't
seen this posted today. So, this
actually uh
reminded me of some But yeah, no, she
definitely was. I feel like she was she
would have posted. I think she was
angry. She was angry at me definitely
cuz she was lying about me.
>> Definitely angry at Nick.
>> And her justification for being angry at
us was that Tom cheated on her allegedly
at VidCon. And according to her, we knew
about it, so we deserve to get
basically, right? Sure.
Here. Hold on. I'll I'll try to go back
in the thread and find it if I can't get
someone to send it to me. I'm looking to
try to find. And by the way, just be
clear, I didn't know about her getting
cheated on. I also didn't really know
anything about her in particular. Tom
told me he was dating some girl from
Tinder that he had met like two months
ago. He told me that, "Oh, I'm Yeah, I
He was talking about some girl." And I
was like, "Are you dating somebody?"
He's like, "Yeah, I've been dating some
girl whatever for 5 months." And I'm
like, "Oh, okay." I didn't know her
name. I didn't know her face. I didn't
know anything about her.
>> Is that okay? I got Well, Bo leaked that
there was a girlfriend maybe, but
>> hold on. We're going back in the thread.
Hold on. Uh for
>> he says page thread moving.
>> Page 378. Ah
>> 378.
Okay, we've got Sacramento right here.
Got Gatorades right here. going up.
Uh, I think the Anon VidCon girl that
Sacramento was talking to would actually
know who Nick Dioro's girlfriend is.
Yeah, I don't know who it is. She does.
She told me that girl was apparently
long-term girlfriend. She's known since
elementary school. Go back up. Oh, I
don't want to free school the thread, so
I'm just I'm reading along here. Give me
a second. Uh, yeah, hold on. I' I'm
looking at the post. Give me a second
before I pull it up on stream because I
just don't I I don't know what
information's in the thread. And if I
pull the thread up, like the thread name
has information at sub. Just give me a
second. Right. Nick knew Tom was
cheating on me and going after girls in
Destiny's orbit in the big 2025 after
Destiny was already exposed to this was
covering for him so hard. Who else know
who else what he knows? Nick, it's over
for your friends. You're a freak and
everybody knows it. Why the you covering
for him? And then this Gatorade's
response, not sure just how strong you
feel right now, but if you'd ever truly
like to burn the Tom Nick Doryo
friendship and finally allow Nick to
feel some true consequences for his,
there's a very simple way to do that.
Tell us who Nick Doryo's girlfriend is.
>> And then I do think now, so that gives
us the
>> I told you guys about that post like an
hour ago.
>> Um, you didn't link it though.
>> I I don't feel like you told me about
this post. You you brought posts to me.
>> I definitely mentioned
Fair enough to me. She That sounds like
absolutely. She was saying she was going
to talk to your girlfriend. Yeah, fair
enough.
>> Yes. I You maybe I said something
different. I'm usually just like, "Oh,
can you show me that?"
>> I feel like
>> I didn't link it, but I just mentioned
that she had said that. I I I mentioned
she had said that. I didn't link it.
Just to be clear.
>> Yeah. When you were in the chat, I was
like looking at those messages and I'm
like, "That's not what she's saying
here, so I I need to see that."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Fair enough.
>> That play. Yeah, it does seem like she
was um soliciting docs. Absolutely. Uh
she's also I don't know who would ever
give her like these names given
>> soliciting docs. Soliciting docs is like
asking for the name, but she was saying
she was saying I'm going to docks. She's
saying, you know,
>> I'm going soliciting docs from the um
from the anonymous VidCon girl, right?
>> Sure. Sure. But I think that's already
assumed, right? That's already We
already thought that she was trying to
get the name for herself.
>> Well, it only becomes Docs if she's
willing to publish it.
>> Yeah. So, we thought she was trying to
get the name of the girl that Tom
cheated on her with, not necessarily
Dioro's girlfriend, right?
>> Well, she is also doing that. She is
also doing that.
>> See, what's the motivating factor there
to get Nick Dioro's Why is Nick Dioro's
girlfriend's name important in this
whole situation? If she's cheated on and
she's angry,
>> what is Nick?
>> Obviously, it's the same It's the same
motivation as everything else. It's to
try and ruin Tom's life. I mean, I think
we already established that much.
>> Yeah. No, she's uh totally psychotic.
>> Well, it's not even Tom's life.
like what she's leaked.
>> It's not even ruining Nick's life, but
it's just like a massive inconvenience
to Nick's life and also some random
>> Yeah, it's trying to [__] with Tom's
personal relationships. That's the
ultimate goal, right? Is
>> I'm reading I'm trying to read through
this whole thing right now so I can see
more. Give me a second. Should I put the
Nick thing back on for a second while we
cover this? Cuz I want to I do want to
read through this thread and see if I
can catch up and see how people are
responding to this overall.
>> Yeah, sure. Oh, Jesus Christ. We agree
with him now. So, I mean, is there any
point in watching the stream through? We
agree with him at the dogs. Um,
>> yeah. Well, I want to watch him. No, no,
no. I want to watch him. It's not That
wasn't even why I was watching the
stream. I wanted to watch him see the
boat Chud Logic. That's what I was
watching the stream for. That's what I
want to see. That's what I'm talking I
believe that's like a 20 second clip as
far as I'm aware.
>> I think Lumpy Willy on Twitter.
>> Yeah, it's like literally a lumpy Willy
clip. So, you
>> Oh, hold on. Yeah. Did we read this? I
could have sworn we read this post, did
we not?
>> I showed you guys a couple of these, but
there's a couple more in here.
>> Yeah, he he's missing the actual
That's a problem. He's missing the
actual one where the back and forth
happens about actually doing the docks.
I knew I I read this earlier today where
he's responding to Conspiracy Lemur
about this. He's missing the actual post
that shows that this is happening.
>> Yeah, I read the Listen, I It's fine. I
I just I looked at this and I'm like
based on this I have like I have no
information that leads me to believe she
was good at docs except somebody
referencing it and then I tried to look
at that and what they were referencing
and I still don't see it but I need to
go back further apparently.
Um none of none of the post do used to
defend himself were this. This is just
him them going back and finding stuff
retroactively. Well, I think
>> No, I'm sure they saw it. I'm trying.
>> So I I could see Yeah. What I could see
happening is he probably saw the post.
He knew it happened and then he went and
found posts adjacent and sometimes you
don't have a perfect theory of mind
where like you know what people don't
know and know what you know that's
different, right? So he probably
included that knowledge of that previous
post while he was posting this. Forgot
that like you needed that for context.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Yeah.
Different kind of mistake.
Check 7576 on the thread. Well, that's
probably the one I did read that I did
actually go back and read. Hold on.
Yeah, that's probably the one that I did
read judging by the That's the one that
should be here. I'll I'll actually grab
it real quick and do a screenshot for
people so they can see it on the stream.
76.
Oh, no. That's not the one.
That's not the one. Um, the one that
shows who the object of all of this is
is back further in the thread, but it's
fine. Okay, go to the lumpy willy clip
real quick. This one is not the one I'm
looking for.
Jesus. Lumpy Willy clip in a lot of this
right now. Which one of these is Mr.
Chud? Okay, right here. Perfect.
>> AM her time.
>> The problem that I have with Chud is
that he went public and he started
complaining like, I'm talking about
sensitive society. I'm talking about a
cheeto. It's like, nah, nah, you're [__]
talking about me.
>> Wait, didn't he say that after I maybe
I'm crazy. Didn't he say that after Nick
covered it that he's like talking about
other people? This is the second clip.
Wait, there's another one. Or is it just
this one right here?
Oh, there's two. Yeah. Okay, we should
watch this one first.
>> February.
>> I feel bad for Chud.
>> The goat. Thank you for the phone.
>> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I
don't feel bad for Chud. Chud went live.
This thing came out at like [__] what
was like between 6:00 and 10:00 the
night before and he was up by 8:00 a.m.
saying the great sweep is on and sicked
his entire [__] audience on me. I
don't feel bad for Chud. Not one bit.
>> See, this is the gay. I totally I
totally agree with his point that Chud
like went way too hard way too early and
it was like totally It's just so
revealing though when you see it's like
sick this whole audience on me. It's so
revealing. It's like he tries to act so
above it all, but it's literally like a
couple of on Twitter say, "Oh, you're
sweeping. You're like a fat." It's It's
the worst thing that's happened to all.
>> I Yeah, I'm just not a I think Chud was
like pre he was making a pre-algigation
or something. He's He's obviously saying
I expect like it's one of those things
where it's like you want people to cover
it. So you you'll basically say I sure
hope they do. I sure hope they're not
going to run away. It's not the same as
saying like um you are sweeping this.
you have you are going to
>> when you're first the story like you get
that you know home ground advantage you
can just kind of flex your and just be
like yeah will anyone else touch this or
whatever. I mean me and Chud argued
about this on his show and also in uh
the group chat but it was very it was a
fun conversation. I don't know. I do
think he was like way too like early
with it. Like literally within hours he
was like they're sweeping and it's like
okay who's sweeping? Well, I sorry I've
said it again. That's not it's not
they're sweeping. It's like I sure hope
they don't sweep this. I sure hope the
sweep's not going to come in. Right. I
think that was I think that's a
different thing. Unless he directly said
they're sweeping by not covering this. I
I just don't think
>> like the presumption that nobody was
going to cover this.
>> Yeah. I just think even the presumption
that nobody was going to cover this is
like crazy cuz it's like
>> I don't know big allegations against one
of the biggest commentary YouTubers.
>> Yeah. That's because historically people
have not covered
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's why, you know, if
you throw out that kind of rage bait,
like obviously people are going to, you
know,
respond to it, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But it's it's just
like a different thing. Jesus here. This
is apparently the longer clip. Let's
check this out.
>> I feel bad for the longer Chug clip
right here.
>> Thank you for the follow.
>> I feel bad for Chud now. He's taking I
don't feel bad for Chud. Chud went live.
This thing came out at like what was
like between 6:00 and 10:00 the night
before and he was up by 8:00 a.m. saying
the great sweep is on and sicked his
entire
>> Is anyone else psyched that like
>> [__] a feel bad for Chud. Not one bit
>> on February.
>> The Great Sweep is on at 8:00 in the
morning. Well, guess what? If you don't
go fly back to whatever bonger country
you're in, if you're not streaming by 8
a.m. tomorrow morning, I'm thinking
you're sweeping this up.
>> Holy [__] [laughter]
for whatever bonger country you're in.
The the bonger country the one. Okay.
All right.
>> Okay. [laughter]
>> Kind of person you are.
>> She says she wishes
>> I'm baffled. Just carry on.
>> Maybe if I stopped covering Ethan Klein
one day and people stop messaging him in
his chat where he's like
>> see it's like this such funny cove and
it's like no one's complaining about you
covering. That's not the complaint. You
know that's not a complaint. So crazy.
How is this? Explain to me how it's any
different to what you guys used to cry
about Hassan for. Ogie, explain that one
to me.
>> What? He's talking [__] about you guys.
>> It's not talking. It's It's the same.
I'm going to just make up a criticism
that no one's saying and cry about it.
>> Don't people call him like the Ethan
Klein waiting room?
>> No one People might call him Ethan Klein
waiting room, but no one's criticizing
him for covering Ethan Klein a lot.
They're criticizing him for being
biased, right? They're criticizing him
for lying, for being wrong, for being
biased.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's the same that someone like,
you know, whoever you're criticizing.
Doesn't have to be Hassan.
>> That's a very lovely example for some
people.
>> Hold on. Can I do a quick Hassan
example? Um, you know, people act like
I'm evil because I just want universal
healthcare. I'm People act like I'm evil
because I just want universal
healthcare. Guys, I don't understand. Is
it really? I just don't want
Palestinians. Then people act like I'm
evil. That's uh that's like the thing
I'm witnessing here. All right. Well,
[__]
>> It's just like Israel, bro.
>> Nicholas
Nicholas has to get on this stream
because unfortunately now we're in an
awkward situation where
>> Yeah. Og's avatar of Nick. Oie. Oie.
Make the Nick argument.
>> Defend him.
>> Yeah. No. Defend him. Make the Nick
argument.
>> He can defend himself. He's a grown ass
man.
>> No. No. No. No. But he literally can't.
He literally can't
>> defeat [laughter] himself. Yeah,
>> you know, he he clearly he clearly knows
about himself that he's not capable of
defending himself in the conversation.
So, you need to be here. You need to
>> Okay,
>> put up a fight. Give us something to
hit.
>> Listen. All right. Listen, you know,
amidst all the glazing accusations, just
admit Nick is bigger than you guys. I
know he's just in your chat, but he's
bigger than you guys. [laughter] He's
>> together actually sit there crying.
They're crying in his discord. level
yourselves up and then one day you can
meet him at his
>> Do you think Do you think if I had 5,000
viewers right now, Nick would hop on the
stream? You think that's the actual
thing?
>> Um, probably not. I don't know.
>> I feel like if I feel like if a streamer
with 5,000 followers call him out.
>> Do you think Nick would debate his son?
>> I think he would actually. [laughter]
>> Even though Willie is
>> cuz Willie did. He's got to avenge
Willie. Apparently Willie got
>> That's not I don't think that's a reason
why Nick would do it.
>> I mean, why wouldn't you debate? If
Assan hit you up right now for a debate,
obviously you're going to [__] take
that [__] right?
>> No, I don't think you would do it. I
think you do. I think there a chance.
>> You don't think he would?
>> Makes sense to buy his public image.
>> I mean, just for like I don't know. I
feel like
>> if Assan hit me up, I'm not a debater.
If Assan hit me up tomorrow was like,
"Let's debate on stream." I'm doing it.
It's for the publicity. You're you're
like not as sensitive about like exactly
what people
>> Well, I do it purely for selfish
reasons. I do it for the money and
publicity. I'd be like, why would I turn
this down?
>> Some people some people motivated more
by other things, you know, in certain
ways. You won't you won't instantly see
a bunch of money just from arguing with,
you know, it's not like that simple. And
on the way there, it's a it's a
>> I just feel like a stupid opportunity to
turn down. Like if people were talking
about you being mean to you, saying
you're like a cryptofascist, saying all
these horrible things about you stick in
your head for years.
>> Yeah,
>> I think he would debate Hassan to be
honest with you. I think you just stick
to the exact same talking points he's
used for months.
>> Well, there's plenty of talking to use
against him. Like
in the dialogue tree.
>> Yeah.
>> You think you think so? Okay. So, what's
the first uh Okay, let's let's uh let's
uh role play it then. What's the first
point? You can't you can't debate a
Hassan. Hassan is not as as good as as
you at it. Okay. I'm telling you, Nick
just runs the dialogue tree.
>> I'll train you on. I'll train I'll train
you on. I'll train your weights on. I'll
try and dumb myself down from it. Okay.
>> No, no, no. But hold on. Here's the
other thing is Nick's just going to like
>> Well, you would go after him for the
anti be like, "You lied about this. You
okay? So, how was your
anti-semitic? How was Go for the first
one. What was that?
Well, I don't have any issue with him
being anti-Semitic, so it's not my
argument. But I mean, I would just say
like I mean whatever whatever that was
in the movie. He lied about like the
ship that got captured by the
>> If we want to Yeah. If we want to if we
want to [laughter] just do a proxy
debate, I'm going to go, okay, you
totally celebrated and thought it was
awesome when they captured those
civilians when they kidnapped.
>> I don't have the Hassan talking points
memor. I don't like Assan, but I don't
have like the anti-Asan talking points
memorized. But I'm sure like if you were
to debate Hassan, it's like even if you
were like a complete I think a Cheeto
could debate Hassan. Like he would just
have the talking points.
>> Cheeto would get [laughter] smarter than
I'm not saying he would do well, but I'm
just saying like
>> it would be a conversation you could
accept because you would have the script
in front of you. I'm not saying he would
do well. I'm just saying like, you know.
>> Um
>> No, I think it'd be No, I don't think
it's as easy as you think it is, man. I
really don't think it's as easy as you
think it is. Are you going to do
>> people are in such an echo chamber with
that?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Yeah. Here. Uh, you
celebrated and you totally put on your
stream and celebrated those people
getting kidnapped. Those civilians.
You're Hassan. Go.
>> No, I didn't.
>> Galaxy Leader.
>> Yeah, you did. You totally. You said it
was awesome.
>> I was just I was a journalist. I was
just covering journalistic journalistic
footage.
>> Nope. You were totally psyched about it.
You said it was awesome. You and Nick
were both Oh my god, this is like Rust.
It's so cool. Right. You're
>> Oh, yeah. He said he said there is 10
towns down 10 toes down supporting it.
>> Also, yes. 10 toes down supporting the
Houthies.
>> Trust me, there's like
>> Yeah. Yeah. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Let me let me think
through. Let me think. Let me think
through. Let me think through. What
would he be thinking? What would he be
thinking? Um,
>> he celebrated it. He would say, "Yeah, I
celebrated it. What's wrong with him
forcing a blockade against state?"
>> Oh, this is going to They're not going
to be able We've had this debate and
there's going to be
>> Yeah, exactly. That's where they lose.
That's where they lose every time.
That's where cuz it instantly goes into
that.
>> That's where they lose. But I can't I
[laughter]
already We've had this argument before.
So I already have a different argument,
but I don't think they're going to I
don't know if he's going to say it.
>> Okay.
>> The answer is there's not a genocide.
Nick has to be willing to argue the
genocide, which means know how to argue
the genocide.
>> Yeah. Well, that is it. That is it cuz
you know I mean
skits are posting a little bit, but it
is all downstream from certain political
streamers. Um,
>> yeah.
>> So, their position, their true position,
their true position is there is no
genocide. Nick's true position is there
is no genocide. Ethan's true position is
there is no genocide. They won't say
that. They won't argue that. They can't
argue that. They don't know how to argue
that. They haven't thought it through
enough, but it is all downstream from
certain political streamers.
>> Says there's no genocide.
>> No, he doesn't say that. But that is
ultimately when push comes to shove,
that's where he sits and that's where
his prescriptions are because um
>> in order to call Hassan a terrorist for
the Houthi support, you basically do
have to um
>> argue there's no genocide.
>> No, there's no argue he's a terrorist,
but it's good to condemn him for
supporting it.
>> You have to basically be arguing there's
no genocide.
I see
Assan did open it up with the capturing
the civilians part, but the rest of
everything like the if he if he could
get it back to Hezbollah, then you could
support Hezbollah as him if you think
there's a genocide going on and like
sort of have some support there.
>> Yeah. Um
>> like people the immediate analog
everyone's going to draw is just like
Nancy Germany. It's like is it okay to
enforce a blockade against like a you
know Germany if that was the case and
then no one's going to bite the bullet
where they say oh no actually non-state
actors can never do a blockade even if
there's a the most heinous genocide ever
going on and then or or someone's going
to say well that was so bad it's okay
where do you draw the line on genocide
what genocide is bad enough to where you
can enforce a blockade as a non-state
actor and they would yeah they would
just uh any commentary you
>> Assad knows to have that argument I
don't know if Assad have that argument.
>> I think he does. I think he does.
>> I don't think so.
>> He just said, "I stand 10 toes with the
Houthies." That's all.
>> Yeah, he did. And then and then he I
think he basically pushed that down that
line.
>> Did he? Okay. All right.
>> Yeah.
>> Ron Pride, thank you for the 10 gift,
dude. Let's go.
>> Huge 10 gifties. We're having a proxy.
This is where content's gotten to. We
can't have a conversation with Hassan.
We can't have a conversation with Nick.
So, we just roleplay Hassan and Nick and
have the conversation ourselves. Let's
go.
>> Meanwhile, Meanwhile, Orgie frantically
replies to DMs of Nick going, "Oh,
yeah." I'm n I'm ning every all these
guys from my social. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm still talking to
Nick right now. Implying I was talking
to him earlier.
>> You get some updated talking points from
Nick. Can Nick is Nick through you?
>> You really want to get him on here? I
don't think that's going to happen. I'm
just going to put a a bet.
>> Well, I don't think he's going to come
on here, but I'm
>> I'm just looking to keep conversation
going. Okay.
>> Yeah. We we want the Why are Why are you
against the idea of like, you know,
being just trying to stalem the
argument, giving us like, you know, what
do you what do you think's going on?
What do you think's You know, what would
be the defense?
>> The defense.
>> Surely you're of any of the points that
we're bringing up that we were bringing
up. Where were we before?
>> I can't remember what was going on in
the clip that we were watching. I think
something sprung off of that was
initially.
>> Yeah. Going after Chud. Oh, I mean him
and Chud have like a rivalry or
whatever. I don't really get involved in
that. I like both them both. I like
Chud. I like Nick. I don't really see a
reason to give a take on that. I think
uh they just have differences. I think
you guys have differences.
>> You don't get you don't give Yeah, but
you don't give takes on like what you
know the beef between them. You don't
think you could you could opine on it at
all?
>> Honestly, I just don't really think
about it. Like when I when people that I
like go after each other, I don't really
even analyze what they're bickering
about. I only care about it when I get
involved if they're going after me. So,
I mean, Nick doesn't like Chud because
Chud called him out. I mean, I think I
was very vocal on I I agreed with Nick
on like the uh sweeping stuff, but I
debated Chud about it on his own show.
So, we've already
>> That just feels like a very convenient
like uh and very unique mindset to have
the idea that when two friends are
beefing, you don't analyze it.
I mean, I'll analyze it, but I don't
really have like a solid like, oh, he's
right or he's wrong kind of view. I just
kind of like view it as just I see both
sides. I understand what's happening,
and I don't really want to get involved.
>> I've actually not heard this directly
before, but Nick cut Chut off. Nick like
decided he wasn't going to hang out with
Chut anymore because of that one comment
about like the EHD.
>> People are saying both sides, Andy. It's
not both sides. It's neither side. I
don't really just I just think it's
stupid to just constantly get yourself
involved in things that don't matter to
you, you know?
>> I I suppose I don't understand what the
um
>> I I think it's I don't know. I'm not
sure just But I feel like it's like um
you don't have to get your yourself
involved. Just like speak about it,
right?
>> Yeah. I just don't really care about
what they're arguing about though. Like
I think it's stupid.
>> I I told Chud directly in DMs. I was
like, I would rather us all just get
along, just make content together. Like,
I don't really care about whatever they
disagree on.
Yeah, wouldn't that that would be so
much better. I just don't understand why
we can't do that.
I'm I'm totally on the same page as you.
Okay. What has to be fixed? What do you
think has to be fixed, Auggie, for that
to happen?
>> We just all on the same page.
>> Dioro, somebody has as somebody that's
known Dioro for so long, like he does
not mix with you guys. like there is
something going on. I can't really
verbalize it, but there's something he
came in here every week for like 6
months. Once a week he come around to
go.
>> I was never around when he was
>> He was in the oil course late night. He
was like hanging out late night. He was
leaking stuff around all the time.
>> I was never around when you guys are
friendly. I only have known you guys as
enemies. So, [laughter]
>> he showed me all of his favorite like
old commentary dramas.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we got along perfectly. And
then I I think I literally just said,
"Hey, uh I think you by the way, total
mistake on my part cuz this person is a
terrible human being, but I think I
said, "Hey, you're going after Natsu
Erdite right now for a thing that you
could easily be accused of. I think you
should just chill." I said that on
Twitter and that like totally
obliterated any friendship we could have
had apparently.
>> Okay, everyone's
>> going I don't want to get into like the
going back and getting all this uh the
old stuff. I feel like it's just like um
the issue right now is like
Nick is
very sensitive to Chud making call outs
to him. He Chud made a comment about
Nick and Nick the [__] out.
>> Um
>> yeah, Chud's called me out multiple
times. I mean, I just respond by I like
Chud called me out in the past. I would
make fun of him. Chud called me out
recently. I went on stream to debate
him. I have a very different approach
when it comes to conflict than Nick. You
know, I like to just talk about it
openly and and discuss it. Uh he likes
to distance himself from it. I don't
really see like a problem with his
approach. I think that honestly
>> Well, is the problem with his approach
not that it's antithetical to everyone
doing their jobs?
>> What do you mean? Well, if Nick's doing
something and calling him out ends the
friendship, you can't call Nick out, but
you can call everyone else out.
>> I call Nick out,
>> although I mostly do it privately to be
fair, but I I disagree with Nick plenty
of times. I don't really uh
>> I've called him out publicly, though. I
mean, we had that argument like a year
ago about the um ironically about you
guys about the whole Jtock Willie Mack
argument. And do you seem a little bit
sensitive about that? Was that not a
little bit?
>> I mean, he argued with me. Honestly, he
didn't seem any more sensitive than my
usual arguments go with my friends. I
mean, I argue with my friends all the
time, so but he didn't cut me off. He
didn't make weird snide comments about
me afterwards.
>> Um, so I mean,
>> generally Nick is a guy that I agree
with on a lot of things. So, we don't
really have much conflict anyway. But
when we do have conflict, I haven't
really I mean, we've had fights and
stuff in the past, of course. I mean,
the I think people know like the most
famous argument me and Nick got into was
about like a
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, I suppose I
suppose let's bring this back because
what we were saying a moment ago is you
were saying, "Well, we why can't we just
get along and be friends and make
content together?" Well, because
>> Yeah, I think make content with you
can't make content with Nick. That's the
problem.
>> That's That is the problem, right? Nick
is the problem there.
>> Yeah, you guys want to make content with
him.
>> Well, no, we all were making content. He
was perfectly happy to make content. We
were all happy making content until he
was on the receiving end of anything
from us, right? Whether it was Jstalk,
me, Chud,
>> what was the argument that separated him
from you guys? Was it Willie Mack?
>> So, with JSTalk, it was the Willie Mac
and Aerodite stuff.
>> With me, it was um H3 stuff.
And with Chud, obviously it's H3 stuff.
>> I [clears throat] feel like with Chud
was more like Turkey Tom stuff. There
was like beef before that, but like
recently it's been like the Turkey Tom
stuff.
>> Oh, come on. He was actually cut off
when the EHD call out happened and Nick
just does this thing where he pretends
to be cool with someone and keep
>> Were they cut off or were they just not
talking to each other for a while?
>> Uh uh they were talking to each other in
DMs, but it was just no more collabs on
stream, right? like no more.
>> As somebody that knows Nick, I have not
known him. I don't want to get into
personal conversations, but I
[clears throat] have not known him as
somebody that speak that spoke ill of
Chud or like cut him off up until
obviously recently with the Tom stuff,
but like before that, you know, I mean,
there was obviously some tension in the
air, but it wasn't like cut off level,
you know, tension.
>> Well, I thought the thing was was that
he was not going to go on his stream
anymore after May after that first H3
cut off call out. And that's he don't go
on my streams anymore.
>> Stop giving these cop answers. Stop
giving the cop answers.
>> You don't even stream anymore. What are
you talking about? Who are you talking
to?
>> No, he does not get on my streams.
>> But I don't care about that.
>> Oh, like he has a rule not to go on your
stream.
>> No, he does not want to go on my
streams. I think he said that publicly.
>> I don't care. You're You don't have to
go on my streams to be my friend. Like
that's not how I operate.
>> Okay, we weren't talking about like
being friends. doing the whole thing was
about making content together, right?
>> Yeah. Well, I'm talking about making
someone content with me. That's what I'm
saying. Now, he'll have me on his
streams, I think.
>> Well, yeah. Yeah. Okay. But the whole
Okay, wait. Wait. But let me follow
back. The whole conversation we we were
initially. You said, "Why can't we all
get along and make content? We can't." I
said, "We can't make content cuz Nick's
a [__] problem." And now you're just
It's like you're just saying, "Yeah,
Nick's a [__] problem. He doesn't
want content with anyone."
>> Yeah. Um, I just what I'm trying to
explain is that him
>> what you're trying to do is do anything
other than point to Nick. That's what
you're trying to do [laughter] on me.
>> Come on. You guys are forcing
>> Be real. Be real. You that is
>> talk about how he's a [__] or something
like that. [laughter] No, I understand.
I understand why he doesn't engage with
all of these
>> in what he would view as pointless
convers. I mean, honestly, these are
pointless conversations. I'm not
benefiting myself. Look, look, let me be
clear. I'm not benefiting myself by
calling into this stream. I'm just doing
it for fun,
>> right? Like,
>> if anything, I'm benefiting JTO, but I'm
not
>> but I'm just doing it right now because
I'm legitimately enjoying this
conversation, right? Like I I think Nick
is in like more of a businessminded mode
where he is like working on growing his
channel, his his
>> his stuff or whatever, right? And he
doesn't need to be tied down by like
forcing himself to argue. Do you need to
debate every single point? I know you
guys do, right? But I argue with Aiden
all the time about this. Sometimes
>> Can I just give you a perfect example of
why Nick knew he had that knowledge that
that post on Kiwi Farms existed, right?
He was in here instantly when he had a
fight. He knew he could win instantly in
here. I think that says all you need to
know about the conversations he won't
have that he'll refuse to have, right?
>> I mean, it's smart, right? Only have
conversations.
You could say it's smart, but it's like
it's just describing, right?
>> Conflict avoidant. That is what you're
saying. [laughter] He's a conflict
avoidant.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, I think he has different
perspectives. I think he has different
goals. He has different things.
>> Stop. This is literally the most
dishonest.
It sounds like Becca. It sounds like
>> It's not Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. It's
not even dishonest, though. It's not
dishonest. It's It's literally just
saying that Nick knows he's wrong, so
he's not going to go talk about this.
And that's all.
benefit yourself from having
conversations that you risk, you know,
damaging your brand by. Like right now,
this whole conversation we've been
having where I was talking to docs and
stuff and even now I look bad. I don't
care at the end of the day. It doesn't
really look bad.
>> Well, I think obviously I sound bad. If
you're willing to come in and be like
honest,
>> I think most people in the chat think
that I sound weak right now, but I don't
care about that because I'm just trying
to have like a legitimate conversation
with people. I think if you're Nick, if
you're somebody I the thing is I can
have these conversations with you guys
where I can risk looking bad because I'm
not trying to build a career in this
sort of niche. I'm not trying to elevate
my channel. If I was trying to elevate
my channel, if I was really trying to
like turn myself go on a generational
run, maybe I would be more avoidant of
conversations where potentially I'm not
prepared to handle certain things that
I'm not ready to talk about. Right.
>> Okay. Yeah. This is just like describing
how everyone becomes like a grifter
basically, right? [laughter] It's just
like you you a avoid criticism. Yeah.
Wow. Great strategy, bro.
>> I mean, it's smart, right?
>> Yeah. Lying them to make money is
>> I'm not saying about lying. Lying is not
good. But like avoiding situations that
you don't have to be in.
>> Why is that? What's the problem here?
Wait.
>> Okay. The initial point. So there's not
a problem if you don't want to be on
someone's stream. You have to go on
someone's stream. Again, initially where
this came from was you saying, "I wish
we could all just get along and make
content together and why can't why can't
we?" And you're just not you willing to
say
>> Nick is trying to build something right
now and you guys are trying to take them
down. You're trying to destroy them.
>> I'm just No one was trying to destroy.
Yeah, but no one was trying to
understand Nick is trying to build
something. That is the that is
fundamentally what it says. Nick feels
like he's trying to build something and
he feels like he can't let
>> you guys are like the ankle biters at
the bottom trying to bite at him and
every time he speaks or whatever, right?
Why does he have to engage with you guys
at every single point?
>> He doesn't have to engage us at every
single point. But if you if there's
legitimate criticism of you, you kind of
have an obligation obligation to respond
to it in some way. Yeah.
>> And there is plenty of legitimate
respond to criticism
>> to legitimate criticism. Yes.
Can I explain the um the original valid
point against you? You should respond to
it.
>> Mhm. Like I think my issue was, you
know, I went on that stream with Willie
and I think I didn't express my my
concerns like super effectively, but I
think they were broadly correct, most of
them. And I think the way I expressed
them led Nick to like totally go hard on
me in a stream. And I was like, "Hey, I
think um I think I spoke poorly, but do
you want to just talk about it?" And he
said yes. And then I think he realized
that I did have a point and that like
Willy's video was quite bad and it
missed a lot of stuff that would have
been very easy to figure out and then he
canceled that conversation and refused
to talk to me. He talked to you. You
made the exact points I would have made
and he looked fairly foolish doing it
and it's I feel like I got totally over
where he tried to paint me as like a
complete to his audience and then he
refused to have any conversation with me
after. So that left like a bad taste in
my mouth. So I don't know. I feel like
if he's gonna make those criticisms and
then when I say, "Hey, I think those are
like not I think some of the things you
said that's not true. I could just
explain this,
>> right?" I I think
>> I think reasonably that we were friends
before that. We could have just had that
conversation. It seemed really weird
that he totally dodged speaking to me
after that.
>> After even after he said he would.
>> Yeah, that's a fair perspective. I mean,
I don't you know, I don't really know I
I only knew of you by the time you and
Nick were enemies. I didn't even know
you guys were like friends. Like I knew
he like came under stream. I didn't know
even know how long he came under streams
or whatever.
>> I don't think of him as an enemy outside
of the fact that he's like supporting
Willie Mac lying about me.
>> Outside of that, if he just was like,
"Yeah, Willy Mack's actually a lying
loser." I'd be fine. I don't I don't
need to be enemies with Nick. I don't
want to be enemies with Nick.
>> But it's like, why do I have to answer
for Nick? I feel like every time I come
on here, as much as I like talking to
you guys, it's like I do have to answer
for Nick. I have to be like you guys are
basically asking like why is he a why is
he a drifter you understand why that's a
totally unfair point to make to me right
now right
>> why
>> you understand why that's totally unfair
that's an insane thing to say because I
was just covering Nick minding my own
business and you came into my chat and
started arguing for Nick
>> okay well on that specific point but I
mean just in general we're chilling or
whatever right and you guys are like why
is he a
>> the content I challenged you
specifically on something yeah I
challenged challenged you on something
specifically which was about the doxing
stuff like that because I opened that
conversation, right? And we had that
conversation, but now later on you guys
are bringing it back up and just talking
more generally just about him as a
person, right? And you guys are asking
me to like cycle analyze him. I'm going
to do it to the best of my ability
because he's my friend. But it's like at
the end of the day, there's really
nothing I can say that's satisfying to
you guys unless I were to just go
scorched earth on him and just be like,
"He's a great
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So, okay.
So, so
>> hold on. Just wait. I need to actually
before you go, I just got to say one
thing.
>> One thing. Just separate me and Quman. I
said I'm fine with you not wanting to
comment on that or I think you already
laid out his business strategy that it
is a business strategy. Okay. So, I'm
separate me and him. Quan, you go now
and make your criticism.
>> No, you I lost it, dude.
>> You threw me off.
>> How did you lose it? I told you. Hold on
for a second.
>> You threw me off. That's why I wasing,
dude, cuz I just lost it as you were
saying that. I immediately lost it.
Okay, hold on. Let me walk back. What
was Auggie saying here? Here, I can pull
it up on stream. Augie was just saying
that I feel like you guys, you want me
to totally disavow Nick maximally, that
he's a grifter, that he's a loser.
>> Yeah, sorry. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. You don't have to say that because
you might think the opposite and you
could defend that point.
But if your reading of the evidence
would lead you naturally to that
conclusion, if you were honest, then
don't you think that's a problem, Orie?
>> But I don't think him not wanting to
talk to you guys is like a sign of
weakness. I think it's a sign of
strategy.
>> But you can reframe any dishonesty as
strategy, or it's not about talking to
me. It's about actually responding to
the criticism or at least even just
change maybe or correcting things he
said or whatever. But he doesn't. He
doesn't. It is still just the strategy
is clear. The strategy just be
dishonest. That's the strategy. Be
dishonest for Ethan Klein. That's his
strategy.
>> If he said wrong, I think he should
correct that, right? I would call him
out if he said wrong. So,
>> sure. But okay. Well, I suppose
what has he said recently that
>> it's about being completely in
contradiction to previous daily
principles. that that's usually what it
is without explaining why those
>> previously he would hop on a stream
>> because no no no no no no nothing to do
with the stream stuff I'm talking about
act the actual criticisms that predate
any of the stream stuff um so
like for in the the whole big thing you
know is the snark uh like narrative that
that Ethan runs right same as the
literally the same narrative as the
antifan thing that that Destiny runs
which is the same thing in the Willy Mac
video exactly same thing that said in
the Willy Mac video basically you It's
it's all the same narrative and that is
obviously and you you obviously know
this totally in contradiction. Makes no
sense with any of the things that you
guys would have defended years ago. And
you obviously know that you're totally
on the train. Nick has not reconciled
how he supports every step of what Ethan
Klein does without uh just going, "Oh,
well, yeah, it might be a problem or it
might be bad, but I just don't feel any
sympathy for." And that's what he does.
Like that's what I keep seeing about.
That's what he does every time. That is
not responding to criticism. that is not
uh changing behavior in accordance with
a valid criticism. Nick is dead to
rights on that. He is literally nailed
to the wall. There is no rebuttal on
that and he will never respond to it
adequately. He will never say, "Oh yeah,
my principles are just totally changed.
I think all anonymous uh Reddit [__]
poster should be unmasked." He's never
It's never going to happen.
>> Well, but that's fine. That that is it's
good that you call him out on that,
right? Like why do I have to be involved
in this? Like why do I have to do I do I
have to call him out as a liar too? Like
for you guys to be satisfied? Like if
you guys are making streams calling him
out wait with that. I don't think
there's anything wrong with
>> Okay. So So wait, hold up. So why do you
think you needed to cover the Tom stuff?
>> Because I felt like if I didn't cover a
major allegation that was against my
friend, then that would look kind of
suspicious and bad.
>> It's just the optics. It's just the
optics. Well, I just think you should
give an opinion about that whole
situation. Your friends in the news or
whatever, right? Like, you know, just go
over it. What's the harm in that?
>> What's the harm in giving your take on
how Nick's totally in contradiction with
his previous state principles? Like,
>> cuz it's me. He's my friend. He's my
friend. [laughter]
>> Exactly. So, because feelings
>> Oh, man.
>> Listen, I'm not in the business of
constantly.
>> Is it Tom Fus again? Is that what we're
saying or is that the Is that the issue?
Is [laughter] that
>> Listen, I'm not in the business of
looking for like every little way that I
can critique and nitpick my friends. I'm
sure there's like 10,000 things I could
just
>> That's what I'm saying. I'm not saying
you have to be, but I, you know,
personally, me personally, me
personally, I like to just be even. I
like to, if my friends doing something
wrong, I like to say they're doing
something wrong. And if I would describe
it in one way, someone I don't know, I
describe it the same way for them. If my
friends are pissing me off, then I like
to do that. But like in general, if
you're my buddy, I'm not trying to make
a fool out of you. You know,
>> if you're my buddy, I'm not trying to
>> You're not trying to make a No, I'm
saying you're not trying to. But if
something is happening, why can you not
simply describe it as it is happening?
They're doing something. You see that
you believe them to be doing something.
You see,
>> I did that with Will. That's why Willie
Mack hates me now because I just I saw
what he was saying about you guys and
just about dodging in general. You keep
jumping to other examples,
>> but I understand I I'm certain you were
nowhere near as close with Willie Mack
as you were with Nick.
>> You, Nick, and Tom are very tightnit
compared to any of the other groups you
had. Bo Black is was pretty close, but
you know, not not as close as you three.
And I'm sure Connor, you're very close
to, but the other two are maybe less
close to.
>> So, as far as I understand, you guys are
essentially, you know, inseparable. So,
you constantly going, "Oh, well, this
lesser friend who I, you know, I'm
obviously you obviously don't value it
in the same way, right? So, it's to keep
jumping to that. So, let's just go
through
>> the big issue. Something Nick's saying,
I'll probably go into him in private
about it, right? I'll probably be like,
"Dude, I think you're totally off basis
on here. I'm not necessarily going to go
at him on public because that could be
perceived as like I'm attacking his his
or something like that, right?" Which I
understand to you guys that's a big
thing to say or whatever, right? But I
Nick's doing a thing. I'm doing a thing.
We're tight. If he really is saying
something that bothers me or I feel is
incorrect, my go-to is not just to like
ignore that, but I'm probably going to
go to just be like it's a prerequisite
to be friends with Nick that you don't
criticize him publicly.
>> Well, I've criticized him publicly
before, but like
>> I guess it depends on like what the type
of criticism is. If it's just he has
like a take on some stupid drama, that's
one thing. or if I am criticizing the
way that he runs his entire stream, like
saying that he's a who who won't hop on
other people's streams and stuff like
that, that's a little bit more of like
almost like a character attack at that
point, right?
>> And I don't want to do that against
friends.
>> Yeah. But we're not talking about the
stream thing right now, right? We're
talking about uh
>> I'm just using that as an example,
though.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But this is about
drama coverage. This isn't about just
like some stupid personal thing.
>> What has he said recently that I should
call him out for?
Um, what's the most recent example Nick
doing something absolutely evil Klein
stuff?
I'd have to go back through my I think
he was pretty disingenuous in how he's
painting the Chud stuff. I think even
this where he's like um sort of leading
this whole thing of being like why
hasn't Chud responded to this? I
genuinely regard I I feel like you know
you you you do um Okay, so the lawsuits
the or the DMCA's in fact the DMCA's the
DMCA and the lawsuits in fact Nick has
uh constantly either said he's
withholding judgment or said I don't
have any sympathy for these people or
made slight mistruthful statements like
saying um oh I think a lot of this is
from paid members content when it wasn't
and stuff like that to do with the
fundamental copyright lawsuits that are
that started the whole thing
>> between Ethan Klein and Denn the DMCA
for snarkers of the Reddit.
>> Yeah. Then for the um for the full
lawsuits as well those lawsuits
>> um being okay with say the Denim's
lawsuit that would be that would be seen
as a total sin before. Right.
>> Right.
Would you agree with that?
>> Being okay with the con? Yeah, I think
I'd agree with that.
>> Yeah. So,
do you not think it is Nick is operating
totally in contradiction to previously
stated principles by going along with
that?
>> Um, well, I will say this. I mean, I
that is something that I've actually
argued with Nick about in private over.
>> Okay. [laughter] Okay.
>> I disagree with Nick completely on the
denim stuff. So um [laughter]
>> to me to me right that that is like a
huge so so so here's so
>> the denim's lawsuit the H3 lawsuits all
this huge story absolutely massive story
and Nick is the top H3 orbiter is the H3
news
>> desk when I argued with him about it in
the past I don't cover the Ethan stuff I
don't really even pay attention to it so
I I wasn't equipped enough to know it
just seemed to me based on what he
But do you not think this is the sort of
thing that is kind of like, you know,
maybe worth covering? Maybe worth
covering like how Nick's engaged with
this because Nick is the essentially H3
News Desk. He's the commentary channel
that does H3 News.
>> Yeah.
>> All these all these Pegasus and
>> I have no issue with people covering it.
>> No. No. Do you not think you should
cover it? Why is this different to Tom
for instance, which you felt like you
should cover?
>> I honestly I I'm not even against
covering it. I think I if it's it's
possible that I might look at the thing
is like
no that's totally reasonable but that
because my whole argument here is
predicated on sort of like needling
around and trying to get you to to give
statements that seem like you're
unwilling but if if you're like if if
you're in a position where you're like
let's imagine let's imagine a world
>> I think I would I don't think I'd have a
problem with doing a segment where I
look at what he has to say about the
case and disagreeing with it. So yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Well, that's fair enough.
I think that's totally fair. And that
doesn't sound like, yeah, there's any
rush. It just seems like that's what you
were saying is that you weren't willing
to give a statement.
>> Well, the thing is I'm not rushing to do
it. It's not like I'm thinking like I
need to fire up a stream on this
immediately, but like I have no no issue
with giving.
>> That's fair. But let's say let's say for
instance, let's say I I make a Nick
video. I'm not going to make a Nick
video just to be clear. This isn't like
me setting up. But let's say I make I
feel like you have like a
>> really that really really kicks off like
you know gets a gets a decent amount of
steam
>> junk drawers video but better and
>> yeah junk draws video but like but like
watchable and like not [laughter] edited
like three days and yeah
>> let's say someone makes that would you
be likely to cover it if it was like
picking up steam and people were
interested and Alex Gway was tweeting
about it and there were spaces would you
be like to cover that do you think?
Um, I wouldn't be totally against
covering it. I don't know if I would
rush to cover it though because it is
about my friend and I feel like that
there is a certain level of disloyalty
if I'm like rushing to cover Oh, the new
Nick video, you know?
>> Sure. But what what do you think would
be like uh so what would determine to
you do you think? What would you look to
to decide whether you were going to
cover it?
>> Um what the video is saying, how much I
enjoy the video. Uh, but really just
mainly like the
like effectiveness of like the points or
whatever, right? Like if it's just like
a critique and like Nick's streams suck,
that's one thing. But if it's like a
it's a pretty damning video on stuff
that Nick's like talked about, I don't
know. I think I think I would just base
it off of like how much the video like
when I watch it personally
interests me in a way where I look at it
and I'm just like, whoa, you know, this
needs to be talked about.
>> Okay. All right.
>> Can I just ask real quick? Are you
waiting to see like if it's more cuz
he's your friend, but if it's more
damaging to him, does that push you away
from covering it? Or if it's less like
if it's less damaging, are you more
likely to cover it or if it's more
damaging, you more likely to cover it?
Or is it maybe
>> I think I think he's saying more
damaging, you'd be more likely to cover
it, right?
>> Yeah. If it was like a totally
devastating video, if it's like
>> if it's just some
ag like, oh, Nick's fat, Nick's this or
whatever,
or like or like, you know, he
>> he lied about that girl being his
girlfriend or whatever in those photos
years ago, whatever the people or
whatever, you know, that sort of [__]
>> I think fundamentally what this
conversation comes down to is I'm not
afraid, and I was talking about this
with Chud, but I'm not afraid to admit
that like with my friends or whatever,
right? I'm not rushing to expose them or
to cover them if I feel it's like
unnecessary. I feel like there is like a
level of disloyalty that I feel by just
>> I I agree with you that jumping on like
tiny little things at friends is like
you know what is even the point that you
know like if you're just blowing stuff
up for the sake of
>> the real answer is this
>> that is disloyal. The real, this is the
real thing, right? To truly be like an
unbiased commentary, you really can't
have friends in this community. Like
having friends is where I up, right, in
the first place, if we're really just
being honest, right? But I started this
thing when I was really young. I met
Nick and Tom. We're good friends. I
genuinely like them as people and stuff
like that, right? And as a result, that
does color my willingness to sort of
call them out or talk them because, you
know, I'm not trying to make my friends
look bad. And so, if people want to make
the argument that you should never have
friends in the commentary community,
like if you're a drama YouTuber, you
shouldn't be friends with other drama
YouTubers. I honestly kind of agree with
that. But it's too late. You know,
I met these people. I like these people.
I I just don't I don't see the inherent,
you know, like issue that where you
can't, you know, engage the same way as
you do
>> with other people.
>> It's like an attack on their if they're
up and you're just like adding on to the
pile and you're like, "Yeah, your whole
stream is disingenuous. You run a dog
stream where you just lick Ethan Klein's
balls and you make all these like stupid
lies and you just, you know, suck his
for clout and stuff like that, right?
you're attacking his brand, his
business, and his credibility as a
person. And even if that's all true or
not, you doing that and adding on to
that pylon as a friend, I see as like
disloyal.
>> So, but you're saying like you can't It
doesn't sound like you're saying you
can't have friends as a drama YouTuber.
You're saying you can't have friends who
do immoral things and can't take
criticism about it. That's what you're
saying. Because I I I mean I you know
I've had criticisms of Chad many times.
I've said you know I said Chud lost your
debate. I said Chud lost the debate at
Pisco. You know I will sit there and
criticize Chad's takes I'll talk Chro
with Chud. Ch would talk about me. Ch
makes jokes about you know everyone in
my committee being all this. It's like
you know
>> well yeah I did the same though but it's
I think it's like a it gets into a
different ball game when you're like
fully attacking somebody's like
credibility. But we've done that too.
We've got we've gone at each other over
King Daniel Green stuff. We've gone over
at each other over the um stop killing
game stuff. There's a bunch of dramas
when me and Shard over it and it's just
like car we move on. We move on.
>> Also, just just to be clear, it it only
gets there after you've like not talked
for a long period of time and a pattern
of behavior builds up. You just talk to
somebody the first time it happens. They
end up going like, "Hey, don't you think
this is weird?" They have a criticism.
You go, "Oh yeah, maybe that was weird."
And then right like there's a release
valve if you could just criticize your
friends openly. Like that's to me what
Chud's original criticism was when he
goes like uh Nicholas Yoro I'm talking
to you. He talks about suck it off like
like Ethan Klein's doing or something.
He says Nicholas Yoro yes I am talking
to you. It's like a little it's a little
nudge where it's like a release valve of
like yeah that is a criticism and feel
free to hit me back on something.
>> But it seemed like Nick was like no
actually I'm not doing that. I'm not
getting into that at all. M
>> like personally I think with friends you
could do that even in this space and it
just doesn't seem like that big a deal.
>> Maybe I'm different. I just it really
takes me a lot. It takes a lot. I have
to take a lot of before I fully decide
all right you you know even with Tommy C
somebody I'm not even friends with but
like you know I really refuse to go in
on him. Wait, that's the thing. It
doesn't have to be like a you. That's
the thing. If you don't if you say the
first thing that happens and you're
like, "Hey, that's man." It's not a oh
you.
>> But if if there are people who literally
can't take it when you start saying hey
that's hey that's hey you've done like
three things. Plus everyone I know to be
honest like if
>> everyone I know
>> and I'm talking about real life people
along with internet people is most
people I know if I were to go up to them
and be like hey you they would take that
extremely personally. Now I'm not the
same way. If they were to be like hey
you I'd be like what's going on let's
talk. But most people that I know are
not built like that. They just can't
take it. I don't I'm not around many
people where I can just be like, "Hey,
you you're completely shit." And they
could just take it.
>> Yeah. It's not going that hard. I think
>> like Do you think that's what you're
saying when he says like, "Yeah,
Nicholas, I'm talking to you." When he
like points at him and he makes a he
mocks him a little bit for consistently
doing the EHD stuff. Do you think that
was a you? Oh,
>> sorry. Uh when Chad was saying that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. When he did that first call
out or whatever, like do you think that
was a you?
>> I'd interpret it that way.
>> But obviously I think Nick probably did.
>> Yeah. I think that's I think Nick saw it
a different way. Look,
I I do not take any I really try not to
take anything seriously at all. You
know, like when people when Chub was
calling me out and said my streams are
[__] I'm
>> Yeah. I mean, like genuinely though,
like when Chub was calling me out saying
like, "Oh, my my RFC mania was like
you're some falling off streamer doing
tricks for cash or whatever the you
know,
>> tricks for treats."
>> I didn't take that super serious. I made
fun of him back. You know what I mean?
But like I didn't take it super
seriously. I think if you said were to
say the same thing about Nick, Nick
would be like, "All right, you're off."
And I respect his perspective. I just
look at things differently. I don't
really uh
I'm not really like I maybe I'm just not
a combat and maybe that's the problem.
I'm in the drama industry but I'm not
like a super combative person. I really
am not. I'm not looking for a fight with
anyone. I don't really am not looking
for that energy. I look for a fight with
people that I already don't like and I'm
not friends with in the first place. But
people that I am friends with, I'm not
looking for that kind of tension. So
maybe I'm just like a non-combative
person and maybe that's like a problem
with doing drama content. I don't know.
But I I don't see it as a problem. But
maybe that's just like the difference of
>> No, it's actually a huge It's actually a
huge benefit. It makes you way way more
successful. But that it's it does lead
to having a bunch of dishonest friends
sometimes.
>> Well, possibly.
It's definitely possible.
But I'm really not looking for that kind
of energy unless it just is it's no
there's no other option, you know, like
Tommy C went off on me today and I'm
just like, "All right, there's no other
option. We're a lock and Tommy C for the
end of the year. Tommy Cy has to
suffer." But it took a while for me to
get to that point, you know? So,
>> wait, you mean you're a Tommy C now?
Well,
>> yes. Now, you're now a Tommy C.
>> Yes, but look at how long that took,
right? I mean, I thought you I thought
you already kind of had gone in on him
to be honest. But
>> no, I was always kind of like, ah, he's
cool. He's cool or whatever. Today, he
just was saying crazy. I'm just like at
this point, it's like [__] this guy. But
it really takes me a long time to get to
that point. So, that's just like an
example.
>> But I mean, let's think again again. I
feel like it doesn't have to ever like
if you Yeah. For a lot of I feel like it
could just be
with Nick. Okay. Because we just we are
constantly bringing back to this. I'm
trying to stop bringing back this but
that's what the conversation is about
whatever for ages
>> with Nick it's like you point out one
thing you point out the second thing a
third retired thing maybe doesn't have a
problem with that then the moment you
ask question well Nick you've done all
of this Ethan Klein cogs in a row that
seems to be seems to be slight slightly
off but not quite line up um is this
maybe being done for a reason you know
you have that's where the problem comes
in that's where that's where it seems
got the problem comes in and you're
willing to sit there and say, "Oh, yeah,
Nick may have this up or may have that
up, but what but you're not willing to
take uh the the second step of of
drawing any conclusion that might
reflect badly on him." And it's like
that that's where I see there's kind of
like a problem because I feel like if
you were commentating, you know, over
anyone else, it it would be it would be
a matter of okay, well, I see you've
done these stereotype things. This seems
to be the way you're acting and it seems
that the reason why you don't want to do
that is because Nick Nick can't take it.
Um, yeah, that's a fair perspective. I
can to I I can definitely see how you
think that. Um,
I just see it as like I'm not looking to
cause a problem between me and Nick.
Nick's been nothing but good to me. So,
I don't really see any motivation to
sort of uh cause any problems for him.
>> You're you're not sweeping for yourself
very You said your broom's very
powerful, but you're not sweeping for
yourself very well. There's like a you
kind of
>> I understand. It's just a losing
argument. There's nothing I can There's
nothing I can say here that wins. It's
It's fine. But you just said like you
just said something that's worse than
what you said before. I think you said
that you think this is just a business
strategy. He's just trying to make money
any way he can. Embedded in that is that
like he's not going to be honest and you
you're saying it. You just don't want to
go hard on Nick and say he's a lying
he's a lying fat and he deserves to like
get cut off at the knees. You're not
going to say that. You don't have to go
that far. You're saying all the things
you need to say to get like the meaning
across.
>> This is a conversation where it's like
>> I personally think it's fine. This is a
conversation where it's like you either
say something and I know Queen is going
to say well if you you know blah blah
blah that means you really believe it
but look like all I can say is either
Nick acts in a certain way and I respect
that or he's a giant who runs from
conflict and Queen would say that oh
well that means that you think he's a
>> but it's like dude
>> yeah those aren't mutually exclusive.
>> He's doing his thing. I'm not bothered
by what he does.
>> No fair trying something else. string on
something else. So, now that Brandon
Bucket was going around doxing, Salvo's
back in the house, right? [laughter]
>> Bring him in, dude.
>> Oh my god.
Brandon had shatter the Overton window
there. [laughter]
>> What do you think about um two
multi-millionaire male YouTubers being
roommates? What do we think about this?
>> Two male YouTubers being roommates.
>> Yeah, two multi-millionaire male
YouTubers being roommates. They don't
make
>> What was that word you said before?
>> Male. Male. Male.
>> Okay. Just male.
>> It's not women living together. You
know,
>> nothing wrong with that. What's wrong
with that?
>> What? You think it's gay? You think
they're like
>> I think it's just like a little bit
strange. It doesn't randomly have like a
wife and kid.
>> Uh
yeah, I think so. Uh
>> he's like roomies with like some
20-year-old.
>> I don't know. YouTubers, dude. YouTube
people have uh content houses and [__]
like that. It's
>> they don't make content together.
>> Yeah, but I'm sure they talk about it
strategies. What kind of question is
this?
>> Brian's out of work.
>> You think it's gay that they live
together? Why? Maybe they're good. Maybe
they just get along with each other.
>> Maybe they just like living together.
What's going on there? Tom is hung like
a Bulgarian like mind worker. Okay. And
Brandon's been out of for a while. We
all know what's going on there.
>> That sounds
>> No, wasn't gay at all. That wasn't what
I was implying.
>> Maybe they just like spending time
together. I don't Is that gay? That
sounds like a good male bond. A good
male. Sorry about being gay.
>> I'm literally not calling them gay. I
literally said Tom is his bull. That's
I'm trying to make a I'm making it a
[__] joke. Can you pick it up, Auggie?
Please.
>> Wow. Thank you.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
>> Yeah, I'm not even saying they're gay.
I'm just saying like the idea that you
know you're like he doesn't make
content, right? Brandon Buckham's
totally out of commission for the last
six months. So they're not they're not
doing cont a content house. They're not
really strategizing,
you know. It's just like a some
40-year-old dude with a wife and kids
like roomy.
>> 40 years old. I don't think he's that
old. I think he's 20s.
>> What is the health problems? Is he on
drugs or something?
>> I don't know anything about his drug
use.
>> Oh, sorry. Like have you [laughter]
>> I don't really know much about Brandon
to be honest at all. Like I just I've
met him a couple times. I I don't um I
don't have I don't think he has like a
super favorable opinion of me. Um I like
him though.
>> By the way, just say there's nothing
wrong with it. Just say it's like fine.
They're friends. Who cares?
>> They They are. It's
>> They probably like each other. They
probably have
>> Don't let this Don't let this British
twink push you around. [laughter]
>> I'm not I'm I'm pushing back.
>> All right, good. Was it even plugged in?
That's [laughter] a good question.
>> It wasn't even plugged in. You know
there was there were no beeping sounds
in the video that Brandon technical. Did
you know that?
>> Maybe it's for weird.
>> Really now? Okay. This is just getting
into like levels of just [laughter]
>> this is just a this is beaming on um the
guy Queenie used to be friends with
before he banned him from his Discord.
>> No, no. Augie Augie spoken to Perry.
Oie's spoken to Perry.
>> Oh, Auggie knows who Perry is. Okay. All
right. I didn't know that. Cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool. Oh, true. Augie was
roommates with X8. That is they couldn't
possibly be gay to live with another
man.
>> True. I live with Got
>> There's a There's a bias here. I'm
speaking to a
>> live be honest on this topic.
>> Didn't think about that.
>> It's not the same though if you're both
like in your 20s. It really isn't the
same.
>> You think there's a difference between a
guy in his 20s living with somebody in
their 30s or whatever?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's a difference.
>> I can see like 20s and like 40s. That's
like crazy. No, there's nothing crazy
about that. You guys are insane.
>> Brandon Buckingham age. It's having a
wife and kids. It's more than age having
a wife and kids.
>> Having a wife.
>> Yeah. Okay. It was having a wife and
kids and living with like some kid.
>> Yeah. Tom's like the older brother.
What's wrong [laughter] with that?
>> Well, like I even wonder like he they
live there with him. Is that like what
how it is or
>> I don't know his living arrangement,
bro.
>> That's like bizarre. That's like so
bizarre.
>> Is that like a hang up? Do people in
England do do British people not room
together? I mean, it's like a
>> Yeah, but like not when you've got like
a like you're rooming with like a white.
>> Also, when you've got no resources,
that's why you room together. Yeah, but
there's no restraint on these two.
There's no restraint. That might be the
only way to see that guy. Okay. You
might that might be the only way you get
to see that guy if he's married. He's
got to have
>> If I'm married, if I'm married and I
live with my best friend, that's like
the best arrangement I could possibly
imagine. I'm not confined to my stupid
wife and my whiny ass baby kid. I have
my friend around me and stuff like that.
That's a good arrangement. That's a
solid arrangement. I like that.
>> Tom can give fashion advice to your
kids. Sorry.
>> Um
>> Oh, that's a that's a joke about
[laughter]
age playing. Oh, I get I get the joke. I
Sorry.
>> I mean, he definitely likes that stuff.
I I don't need Augie's comment on it.
It's fine.
He definitely likes that stuff. I just
personally am of the opinion that, you
know,
the age play or the kids, Jason, you
have to clarify otherwise.
>> The age play obviously.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> I'm not totally down with people being
obviously don't think Turkey's
obviously.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> I'm just saying if he likes uh
you think he's definitely doing age
play. What? Because he met met up with
the girl.
>> Um met up with the girl. I think there's
like a little some little interesting
>> Oh, wait. No, this will be good. This
will be good. Okay. Do you think Kai is
lying? Do you think Kai is lying in her
statement that she says she's not into
any age play?
>> I don't know her enough to say if she's
I I I take her word as true. I don't
know her personally. I don't
>> you you don't have like some other take
on it. You don't feel like you
>> I mean I just think it's true. Why Why
do you think she's lying? Let's hear.
Well, because Aiden, so the the story
is, and this basically confirmed, is
that basically Lis was gossiping to
Aiden and says years ago when she goes
back with Tom or whatever, oh yeah, she
she pre
or whatever.
>> And um Aiden takes this and leaks this.
And when Aiden leaks it, Lar reaches out
and says, "Hey man, I was just gossiping
and making you know, I was just making
up all the time back then. you know,
like like the stuff I told Jaylen, but
like all the stuff he told Jaylen was
like basically true. I think Salvo made
up the idea that he carved her name, but
the I believe that as far as we can
tell, he did pro he seem to self harm,
you know, um did there was cheating, you
know, all this stuff did seem basically
happened, he said Jaylen. So, as far as
we can tell, everything else he leaked
or gossiped about was true. Uh but
apparently now this one is the one
that's false. And it just so happens
that it totally benefits uh Liam, who
has a history of allegations, lollycon
allegations against him. It benefits
Kai, who's planning to start a streaming
career soon?
>> I think that Liam is the one that was
doing the age play. All right.
[laughter]
>> Do you think Liam was the one doing the
age play? Which way round? Him
pretending to be a child or Kai
pretending to be a child?
>> Well, I don't know. I definitely think
he was involved in some sort. I think
they do both.
>> Both. Both. Yeah. I think Liam was the
one that was doing it. Um, if I were to
throw like a speculation like that. But,
um, I did hear your take. You were
basically saying like because so Kai's
trying to start her own streaming career
apparently.
>> I don't think she wants to follow in. I
don't think she
>> obviously she doesn't want like a
nuclear war with Tom to interrupt that.
>> Not just that, but just she doesn't want
to be known as an age player, you know,
like you wouldn't you would go into
streaming being known as
>> I mean that's definitely a possible
motivation there. Um, is she lying
though? I mean, I I take Tom at his
word. He says he hasn't done that. Kai
says they didn't do that. Uh, the weird
Ellie girl said they don't do that. So,
prove it. That's what I say.
>> Yeah. I can't prove it obviously. I just
I don't believe her. I think that's a
lie. I think that's too convenient. And
Lar said it at a time where I don't
think he would have just
>> uh
>> lied about that cuz the other stuff
wasn't nice. Would you go fly out to
hang out with a girl who was wearing the
stuff that that girl was wearing or
>> no? No. No. No. That person was
>> No, cuz that obviously that person's
into some weird sick [__] I mean, I
don't think that that necessarily means
that Tom was engaging in that with her.
I think he probably just saw some girl
that was like he thought was hot on
Instagram, was like, "Let's" But a
person like that is like, "No, you got
nothing. That that's not a the good type
of person you want to be hanging around.
That is no no go.
>> What do you What do you think you
thought was hot about it? I'm sorry. Uh
>> probably that she was an adult woman
that's into the e-girl aesthetic and he
probably liked that. I don't know.
>> Yeah. Okay. I'm not going to press any
more.
>> I mean, not every picture, just to be
clear, I've seen like the sketchy
pictures of her. Not every picture of
her she looks like that.
Just to be clear. So she very obvious of
her. Do you think if somebody off their
pedophile?
>> No. No. They met her in real life. No. I
feel like if they were like cruising
Instagram and they saw pictures of Bel
Deline looking like a little kid and
they slid in the DMs based on that and
tried to [__] her then I would be like
>> I mean Belie's like obviously an adult
though.
>> Uh yeah.
Yeah. I'm saying
>> every picture I've seen of Beline
online, like on Twitter, she looks like
>> But like how old is Bel Deline? Like how
long has she been doing this for? Like a
decade.
>> I would say when she was younger, she
did look young. She looked like way
young.
>> I don't know. I'm just thinking about
her like when she was doing content like
Touad and stuff like that, when I'd see
pictures of her, she looked like a grown
woman. And if somebody was attracted to
that person, I'd be like, "Oh, you're
attracted to grown women."
>> Okay. Show the skirt picture. I'm not
going to show the skirt picture right I
mean, you're obviously attracted to like
some weird egirl BBD hoe, but like
you're still attracted to a grown woman
at the end of the day, right?
>> Does she look like a old?
>> Yeah. Well, hold on. I don't think I
don't think that makes you a
>> But I think you see something there that
you want to go hang out with
>> that is weird. I agree with that. I I
think that that's definitely
>> but but also I don't I just as long as
he's not like for me the way I look at
this is if you have the self-control to
not talk about this and you just kind of
like like some aesthetics around this
and you're only talking to adults then
I'm totally fine with all of that.
Right. I don't have a problem with all
of that. So I have no problem saying I
suspect that he's like kind of into that
stuff. I think there's
>> I don't give a [__] about it either way.
My my issue is literally the the way he
presents online is is just like
>> Oh, it's hypocritical, too. Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's just it's the it's the gay as he
does this gay puritan attitude. You do
it to a little bit orgy as well. I'm not
going to lie. Um the like commentary
Kend Doll where you just sit there act
like oh so crazy that anyone could be
could be I mean to be honest you're both
doing it right now being like oh how
could anyone be interested in this girl?
She's wearing kid clothes in this one
[__] in this one picture. It's like,
well, because she looks like a [__]
only fan's going off for pictures.
That's That's why.
>> Well, that's what I'm saying. I've I've
never Wait, Augie said that. I've never
seen those pictures. I've only seen the
uh the youngl looking ones.
>> Um, okay. Wait, Queen, did you just
accuse me of having that same position
or do you think I was hinting at that
same position? I said right away.
>> I see you. You were doing I said you
were doing that thing with regards to
that that girl.
>> I wouldn't [__] somebody that looks like
a child. I Yeah, I was saying that like
there's a reason he wanted to meet up
with that girl, right? And I'm I'm
saying that I don't think that that's
like necessarily sick because it's with
an adult, right? That he confirmed as an
adult before he went to find her or went
to see her. I don't think there's like
necessarily necessarily something sick
there. I just don't think you should
talk about like your fetishes and stuff
broadly on streams. I think it's like
>> mostly especially show.
Well, I think I don't think you should
because it's like embarrassing, but do
you think there's something wrong with
doing it?
>> Unless you're Mr. Girl, you can get away
with it.
>> I especially if they're society wrong,
it is like a lack of self-control that
you feel like you need to talk about it
that I think is concerning. It's like
for example, the the food shops like um
stuff where she felt like she had to
talk about it.
I think that lack of self-control is
very uh
>> yeah, I want to pass out the difference
between there being like an action
that's wrong versus an action that's
sort of like transgressive and maybe
could reflect on the person a certain
way but isn't 100% cuz it sounds like
you're saying this is something it's
like a red flag to me like I I look at
someone with a side eye if they're doing
this but are you saying it's wrong to
do?
>> Um how do I put it? I'm not sure it's
wrong to do. I don't feel like I'm
saying it's wrong to do. I'm saying it's
like um like I'm concerned about that
person being like having some uh like a
lack of self-control.
>> Sure.
>> I'm like less committed. I do think
there's probably something to be said
for like um like normalizing certain
things. There's conversations about
normalizing certain things that I think
could be weird, but I it's probably
where people who have thought about it.
I don't mind people doing um like
thoughtout pieces on stuff like that if
they've got like some argument they're
making. they're presenting something
novel, but if they're just like, I don't
really care about this. They're having
like a conversation about it. I think
it's it's weird. It comes off as to me
as weird. I don't know if I go so far as
to say it's morally wrong.
>> Sure.
>> But yeah, like um I don't know. Like
food shop's just a perfect example of
like there was literally no benefit to
you doing this and you had to talk about
it. That makes me very concerned. And
then obviously the lies that went along
with it as well. There major red flags
going on there.
>> Yeah. I I think to be honest I don't
really put that much on talking about
the lies are the bigger issue. I I
guess, you know, I do look at, you know,
I'm the I'm the same where it's like,
you know, someone says they're into I'm
obviously look at them with a side eye,
but I don't see anything. I'm not I
don't think it's a wrong act to admit to
being into, you know, it just makes you
seem like there's a increased chance
you're a repetitive.
>> Yeah. I think what I'm doing there is
adding the weight of like how socially
I don't know how much of a social
outcast you look like when you do that
and that somebody willing to do that
like um somebody who's willing to do
that. I think yeah probably poorly
socially conditioned.
>> I think it depends how much
>> of really I think it depends on how much
looks maxing. I think it depends on how
much you're looks maxing.
>> I mean, that's like the real answer for
like basically everything pretty much.
It's like
>> this is why Epstein was not
>> like some guys can just get away with
it. Like I was having a conversation
with somebody about like Flamco and they
were like, "Didn't Flamco his argument
about why he looked at is because he
imagined himself as like the little boy
getting
>> Yeah, exactly. And I'm like, yeah, the
reason why that argument doesn't work is
because he looks like the if he was like
a looks maxed like guy, he could
probably maybe have gotten away with
that, but because he looks like a
disgusting got in this same turkey
drama, he would have gotten away with
it. Nobody would have even batted an
eye.
>> Well, the girl wouldn't have even
reported him, right?
>> Yeah, I think
if it was Hassan.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I believe that.
I'm pretty sure I can't remember what
the stat is, but there's like some crazy
stat about like there being a huge
crossover between like auto
so when you see yourself as a kid so so
like when people say like I've heard
trans people say that [__] as well where
they're like oh I was looking at the
because I myself as a kid it's like it
doesn't actually make it any better like
statistically I'm pretty sure it's like
actually you're just as like
>> that's one of the leading theories for
how develops right you get somehow Like
that's why there's such a high
correlation with sexual as a child.
>> Yeah. A lot of the time
>> is you you crystallize like your
development as you with you as a child
and
yeah like it halts there. You get like
arrested development of your
>> I don't know. I think we should ask
Destiny what he thinks about this. He's
in the chat, right? [laughter]
>> I don't think so. Uh I don't think
tonight.
>> Damn.
>> He is on vacation though. That is when
he tends to come in when he has to hang
around other human beings, catch a
stream.
>> So, you never know.
>> Is he somewhere with not soite? If if he
was somewhere with not a erodite, he
would definitely be in the chat tonight.
You know, you know it for a fact.
>> Who wouldn't?
>> You got to escaping her.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm probably going to bounce
out of here, but uh
>> All right.
>> Good talk. Good talk, guys.
>> Yeah, we'll chat later. See you.